Guten Morgen Linus.
Morgen, Liebe. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich äh bin irgendwie immer noch so auf Pluto eingestellt und komme da irgendwie noch nicht so ganz,
zurecht, aber ich merke natürlich schon äh wie die Gravitationswellen hier einiges in Wallung gebracht haben.
Netzpolitik hundertneunundsechzig äh live aus dem Raumfahrtkulturzentrum im Preslauer Berg,
Ja, habe schon immer geahnt. Jetzt äh jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir so ein äh können wir mal gucken, wie wir das Ding nennen, ne? Kann ja jeder auch einen Vorschlag machen.
Ne, er ist ja eher äh IX.
Ja, Pech gehabt.
Tut's allen wieder leid.
Nee, was der andere Name, oder sowas, ne, bei den.
Ich habe noch nicht genau geguckt, also.
Den Lunis gibt's dann immer so verschiedene.
Also nach wem könnte man jetzt gerade meinen Planeten benennen? Jetzt ärgert man sich natürlich, dass wir Lemmy Kirmes da schon für dieses äh für dieses chemische Element äh verballern wollen.
Das Element vorgeschlagen. Ja, mal gucken, ne? Ne, ich meine, David Boey würde sich noch anbieten.
Bowie. Ja, das wäre schon, also der hat Bowie ein.
Könnte schon mal Planet ja einfach Planet Bowie. Warum nicht?
Naja, wir haben das wahrscheinlich am Ende wieder nicht äh zu entscheiden, wie immer. Nee, wir haben so gute.
Uns fragt wieder keiner. Keiner fragt die Basis.
Die Basis ist raus. Nee, das äh die wahren Entscheidungen werden immer in kleinen Kreisen gefällt. Weißt du, wie das ist, ne? Ist schlimm.
Genau. Aber immerhin äh wir arbeiten dran unsere Basis äh zu verbreitern und die Zirkel etwas aufzubrechen und äh haben heute noch einen Gast an Bord.
Den Alexander Alexander Sander, hallo,
Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Ähm.
Alex, du bist ähm ja, du bist äh aktiv und zwar bei der digitalen Gesellschaft.
So ist es.
Vielleicht kannst du ja mal selber,
erzählen, was da so euer äh Zentral eure zentralen Inhalte und Aktivitäten sind.
Ja, die ist äh ein Verein hier aus Berlin. Wir setzen uns ähm für Menschenrechte im digitalen Raum ein und für Verbraucherschutz. Ähm wir arbeiten an sehr, sehr vielen verschiedenen Themen. Ähm es geht von
Überwachungsskandal, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Vorratsdatenspeicherungen,
bis hin zu Themen wie Netzneutralität oder auch Urheberrecht. Also wir beschäftigen uns eigentlich schon mit allem,
was relevant und wichtig ist im Bereich Netzpolitik und versuchen dort eben Entscheidungen herbeizuführen, die eben ähm positiv für Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und für alle Leute da draußen sind.
Eure primäre, wie soll ich sagen, also,
was siehst du so als euren Hauptwirkungsvektor?
Würdest du die.
Wir sind wir sind eher so ein Haufen von Lobbyisten, wenn man, wenn man so mag, also wir machen natürlich vorher Analysen, die veröffentlichen wir auch auf unserem Blog,
und reden dann im Anschluss mit Entscheidungsträgern und versuchen dann eben tatsächlich im Gesetzgebungsprozessprozess
sein, dass wir selbst mit Gesetzesvorschlägen uns ähm im Parlament einbringen,
ähm beziehungsweise versuchen, dafür zu lobbyieren, dass diese Vorschläge dann eben auch genauso in den parlamentarischen Prozess eingebracht werden,
Ähm das kann zum Beispiel im EU-Parlament sein, dass man versucht durch Änderungsanträge, die man
dort formuliert diese auch in diesem Prozess mit einzubringen, so dass dann eben Gesetze entsprechend geändert werden können nach unseren Vorstellungen. Ähm wir gehen aber auch äh zur Weile mal auf die Straße und demonstrieren, wenn's dann äh ein Punkt erreicht ist sozusagen, wo wir mit dem Lobbyismus nicht mehr wirklich weiterkommt, so wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Kommunikationsdaten.
Da haben wir in der Vergangenheit dann eben auch demonstriert, wir machen Briefaktionen, verschiedene Dinge, aber also es ist jetzt,
eher so, dass wir versuchen, ähm schon im Vorfeld sozusagen die.
Ja, dazu gehört natürlich auch so ein gewisser Früherkennungsaspekt, also man muss dann eben auch die Nase schon äh längst im Wind haben, wenn die Düfte anfangen herüberzuziehen,
häufig
Wird man ja oder wurde sagen wir der Aktivismus auch immer ganz gerne überrollt von mehr oder weniger fertigen Ergebnissen mit Klassiker ist immer so, oh der Bundestag will morgen über irgendwas abstimmen, äh das gefällt uns aber gar nicht, da sind wir ja jetzt mal kurz dagegen,
äh bringt natürlich herzlich wenig. Was würdest du sagen, ist so der Zeitpunkt, wo man eigentlich spätestens.
Ähm ja, das kommt.
Bekommen haben sollte.
Das kommt ganz auf die Ebene an, auf der die Entscheidungen getroffen werden. Ähm im ähm,
auf auf europäischer Ebene ist es so, dass er die Kommission das Vorschlagsrecht hat, also da macht's,
schon Sinn in dem Prozess, wo die Kommission an einem eigenen Vorschlag arbeitet, zumindestens,
zu wissen, in welche Richtung es geht, dort auch schon mit den zuständigen Beamten mal ins Gespräch zu kommen. Und ähm dann, wenn dieser Vorschlag dann präsentiert wurde, dann mit EU-Abgeordneten ähm reden und aber hier natürlich dann auch im Nationalstaat dafür sorgen, dass die Position im Rat,
also wo die Mitgliedsstaaten in der EU dann vertreten sind, dann auch entsprechend ähm in die gewünschte Richtung geht. Also man muss schon sehr, sehr früh anfangen,
Thema, über was wir heute reden, Fluggastdaten, ist ein Thema, was uns seit zweitausendelf,
beschäftigt, also da sind wir jetzt seit fünf Jahren dran am werkeln,
Thema WLAN-Störerhaftung ist auch ein Thema, was uns über Jahre hinweg,
hat, also ähm es gibt eigentlich selten Themen ähm,
wo man nur sagen wir mal ein paar Wochen oder Monate dran am am Arbeiten ist, sondern es sind eigentlich immer so Horizonte, die über Jahre hinweg gehen,
und ähm grad bei solchen großen Gesetzes ähm,
muss man auch extrem lange am Ball bleiben, damit dann eben nicht so was passiert wie morgen wird abgestimmt. Ähm jetzt macht mal was.
Also es sind sind schon meist jahrelange Prozesse, wo man sich schon sehr,
einbringen muss, schon in der Erarbeitung von Gesetzesentwürfen.
Und würdest du sagen, dass derzeit der Trend deutlich hin mehr zu europäischer Aktivität geht oder ist das äh hält sich das noch die Waage oder hat man dann letzten Endes doch National den größeren Hebel, weil man da besser verankert ist.
Also die meisten Entscheidungen kommen schon aus Europa. Also wir haben natürlich so Spezialprobleme in Deutschland, so was wie Wilhelm Störerhaftung oder Massenabmahnung,
sehr Deutschland spezifische Probleme, aber die meisten Sachen kommen tatsächlich mittlerweile aus Europa, Datenschutzverordnung, Netzneutralität, Urheberrecht, all sowas wird alles in Europa entschieden und ähm von daher ist eigentlich die Ebene,
wir arbeiten halt vorwiegend die europäische, versuchen aber natürlich als deutsche NGO dann eben ähm über den Rat auch, also die Position der Bundesregierung zu beeinflussen und natürlich auch deutsche EU-Abgeordnete anzusprechen.
European Digital Whites, unser Dachverband aus Brüssel, die haben dann natürlich den etwas europäischeren Blick auch im im Bereich Lobbyismus zum Beispiel, so dass dann eben da versucht wird, auch ähm auf.
Also die gegessen ist auch unterstützendes Mitglied beim Etri. Hm und mit wie viel Leuten seid ihr so am Start?
Ähm wir sind ähm
drei Leute, die fest angestellt sind und arbeiten, haben meist noch so zwei Praktis am Start und ähm haben so um die fünfunddreißig Mitglieder. Ähm darüber hinaus haben wir halt noch eine relativ große Community, die dann auch immer mal noch ein bisschen Dampf macht, wenn's,
brenzlig wird.
Mhm. Ihr macht ja auch äh hier so eine Veranstaltungsreihe in Berlin, gehe ich mal gerne hin. Äh erster Dienstag im Monat, ne, äh in der Seabase. Finde ich eigentlich immer ganz ähm.
Soll ich sagen? Also sehr beständig. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange läuft das jetzt schon?
Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt so beim fünfzigsten fast. Beim fünfzigsten jetzt politischen Abend, also seit fünfzig Monaten.
So lange wie wir jetzt hier unseren Podcast machen und
Regelmäßigkeit ist äh auf jeden Fall immer mit fast die Größe äh Herausforderung bei sowas. Ich weiß, dass
wohl, aber sind wir sehr unterschiedliche Themen, zwei, drei, manchmal auch ein paar mehr Vorträge, mal mehr Diskussionen, mal mehr einfach nur so Updates über über was auch immer, so ähnlich wie wir das dann eben auch hier machen, aber auf jeden Fall auch immer so ein
Sammelpunkt dieser sag mal nutzpolitisch bewegten Szene und,
Grad an dem Event habe ich auch mal ganz gut gesehen, also korrigiere mich, wenn du einen anderen Eindruck hast, aber soweit ich mich erinnere, das war so vor vier, fünf Jahren,
Da saßen da so zwanzig, dreißig Leute rum und mittlerweile ist eigentlich die Seabase immer voll.
Ist immer voll. Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Uns gibt auch noch einen Stream, also für Leute, die nicht in Berlin sein können, wird ähm live gestreamt auf Seabase Punkt org,
auch nochmal vielen Dank an die und wird auch aufgenommen und wir kippen das danach noch auf YouTube,
sodass man sich's auch äh später noch anschauen kann für Leute, die jetzt nicht in Berlin wohnen oder gerade äh zu der Zeit nicht da sind. Sehr zu empfehlen. Ich find's ein ganz, ganz interessantes Format.
Ja ich auch, vor allem weil's dann auch verhältnismäßig kompakt ist. Es läuft zwei Stunden, ne?
Anderthalb Stunden ähm äh hinzukriegen, weil sonst wird's ja auch zu lange, aber manchmal mit Fragen und Diskussionen.
Und uns hat halt auch, ich meine auch zu, manchmal komme ich hin und
ist eh so voll und und nutz einfach mal die Gelegenheit einfach nur, weil du einfach, ich weiß, da stehen dann irgendwie zehn, zwanzig Leute rum, wenn ich mir die alle zusammen telefonieren sollte, eh, über die Woche, eh, hätte ich da sehr viel mehr mit zu tun. Und da kann man dann halt mal eben schnell
Sachen klären, ne, so äh Einladung aussprechen, Hintergründe abfragen et cetera und von daher,
erfüllt das natürlich hier auch eine gewisse soziale,
Rolle.
Ja, über PNR wollen wir dann auch gleich noch reden, aber ich glaube, äh zunächst einmal müssen wir uns noch hier in eine kleine Feedback äh Schleife begeben und einen kleinen Nachtrag liefern zu einem Thema des letzten Lokboos.
Genau, da ging's um Binge und äh wir hatten ja erst auch selber im Laufe der Sendung den Verdacht erhärtet, wie das denn funktioniert und sind dann relativ,
erst zum Ende hin, dass auf die,
plumpste Idee gekommen, nämlich dass man einfach den Traffic bei diesen Videostreams
drosselt und dadurch dabei auf das auf die adaptive Bandbreitenanpassung setzt, also im Prinzip der Nutzer geht hin und klickt einen.
HD Stream, dann äh ist dazwischen T-Mobile und begrenzt, aber die Bandbreite auf anderthalb MB, der
Server, der die Datei streamt und bereitstellt, merkt,
er nicht schnell genug senden kann und schaltet automatisch runter. Sieht man auch
Tagesschau aus der Mediathek schaut und dann mit so einem äh Unterschichten Provider wie ich unterwegs ist, so dann
merkt man halt so, dass ruckelt ganz schön und da wird halt alles gedrosselt was was,
So, genau.
Und jetzt hat die das Problem wäre natürlich, was,
Anpassung hat,
Ja, also was, sagen wir mal, ein äh naiver Streamingserver, der gar nicht das kann, ja, der vielleicht gar nicht in nicht HD bereitstellen kann,
Und genau das hat die IFF jetzt auch nochmal untersucht und hat gesagt, naja okay, wir haben mal geguckt.
Ähm wenn man ein paar Test Cases gemacht und uns so eine Karte geholt von T-Mobile und,
und sagen OK also erstens,
diese Limitierung auf anderthalb äh Megabit passiert bei Videodateien.
Ob die Anbieter wollen oder nicht. Also es ist eine Drosselung, die einfach mal für alle gilt. Ähm,
funktioniert auch, wenn die HTTP-Headers einen anderen Dateitypen definieren, was so ein bisschen unklar ist, das heißt, woher merken die jetzt genau, dass es sich um Videoinhalte handelt so?
Das kann die IFF auch selber nicht genau sagen, also das wäre.
Kann mir nur vorstellen, dass sie damit einer arbeiten. Also äh die werden da einfach eine Liste pflegen, wo draufsteht das sind für uns die Videodienste, die wir kennen. Wenn du jetzt von irgendeinem Server da einen Video bereitstellst, dann ist das bestimmt nicht.
Spezifisch gedrosselt so.
Das wäre jetzt auch meine Hypothese, allerdings haben sie dann einen Server, haben sie.
Entschuldigung. Blacklist meine ich natürlich, ne?
Ja. Aber dann haben sie, haben sie einen Server aufgestellt, der keine keine adaptive äh Bandbreitenanpassung macht und der ruckelte dann einfach.
Das heißt, da hat wurde auch auf anderthalb Mbit gedrosselt.
Dieser Hypothese sind sie auch äh nachgegangen,
und haben äh einen normalen Datei-Download gemacht und haben damit äh sehr viel höhere Bandbreiten erzielt. Also quasi drei Test Cases, du streamst ein Video, du lädst eine eine Datei herunter und du.
Du du lädst dir ein Video herunter, gibst aber im im HTTP Header nicht an, dass es sich um ein Video handelt. Und in in den,
und in den anderen äh also Streaming im Browser Direct download und direct download,
Non-Video wurden gedrosselt. Also irgendwie erkennen sie's doch ganz gut. Ja, also.
Anschauen und darauf irgendwelche, ja, wie sollen sie es sonst wissen? Ich meine, wenn da alles über harte TPS rübergeht, wie wie.
Der, der, na ja, also genau, erstens,
Ja, es war nicht nur HTPS, wir hatten ja auch elaboriert, dass wenn es HTPS ist, dann müssen sie mehr oder weniger einfach auf Basis des Anbieters gehen oder halt auf Größe der Datei oder ne, also, aber.
Die kennen sie auch nicht.
Na ja, sie sehen ja, dass da auf einmal ein Stream stattfindet. Also nichts ist so einfach zu erkennen, wie ein Videostream oder ein Skype-Telefonat. An der.
Ach so, du meinst, dass sie das sozusagen so so Trafficanalyse machen und so, also das ist okay.
Punkt, auf den ich hinaus will, ist, die haben es untersucht und können keine hundertprozentige,
Aussage treffen und ich ey, ich schildere deren Ergebnisse. Wir können da jetzt noch ein bisschen drüber spekulieren, aber die haben das schon ganz gut untersucht. So, ja. Und sie sagen also, sie wissen nicht ganz genau, wie es geht. Und dieser der interessante Fall ist eben
bei diesen, wenn der harte TP hätte er nicht stimmt und sage ich mal, keine.
Dafür da sind, dass es sich um einen Videostream handelt, funktioniert dieses diese Binge on Drossel doch,
Trotzdem, ja? Also, ob sie jetzt irgendwie nach Markern wie Video ähm.
Äh was weiß ich wie in dem Video Code in dem übertragenen Teil nach irgendwelchen Markern suchen oder nicht, ist irgendwie unklar,
Also ist nicht ganz so einfach, dass sie einfach nur sagen, okay, YouTube grundsätzlich nur anderthalb Mbit. Das haben sie wahrscheinlich auch, aber ihr, was auch immer sie da jetzt einsetzen kann, auch,
sage ich mal, bei der Tele,
nicht bekannten Videostreaming angeboten,
erkennen, dass es sich um ein Video-Streaming-Angebot handelt und das sogar auch, wenn,
das ein bisschen verfälscht und jetzt nicht, sage ich mal, die offensichtlichen Marker dran sind, wie HTP Header oder Filextension, die jetzt einfach erkennbar wären.
Also mit anderen Worten, das würde auch bei äh wie gesagt, bei MediaZ, sagen wir mal.
Wäre mal interessant.
Media CTC würde das eben auch einfach,
bei WDR CCA, wobei ich nicht weiß, ob Media CCC DE,
automatische Bandbreitenanpassung macht,
Da bin ich gerade nicht im Bilde, weil ich in der Regel einfach HD beste Qualität.
Ist vielleicht gar nicht so das Ding oder ist halt eher die Frage Streaming, in dem Moment, wo du halt HLS äh Streaming machst, also also adaptive ich halte mehrere Bandbreiten äh vor und bilde das aus, was am besten oder beziehungsweise der der Klein wählt ja aus, was äh,
Was sozusagen äh letztlich abgefragt wird, weil er merkt, dass äh die anderen Häppchen nicht schnell genug kommen. Schaltet der Kleint ja dann selber runter,
Muss man sehen. Äh sicherlich noch ein paar Tests wert. So oder so ist es vollkommen offensichtlich, dass hier T-Mobile USA halt
einfach mal genau das macht, was äh Kritiker einer
Netzneutralitätsregelung, also eine antinetz Neutralitätsregelung immer kritisiert haben. Und das, obwohl es jetzt eben
die eigentlich äh korrekte ähm Definition für Netzneutralität äh ja eigentlich geschafft hat in den USA
Jetzt wird's natürlich spannend zu sein, zu sehen, ob die FCC hier auch
Regeln nicht nur auf dem Papier stehen, sondern sich eben auch real im Netz messen lassen.
Jo, was noch ganz schön ist, dass sie dann eben Mitte in,
telefoniert haben mit weil ja,
der John Leger ja groß erzählt, dass optimiert, optimiert, optimiert und so, ne? Und dann haben sie halt
weil Timo, weil angerufen haben gesagt, ja äh wie sieht's denn hier aus so was seit's irgendwie so von Optimierung wen ich jetzt unbedingt zu erkennen und da haben eben auch am Telefon die Antwort bekommen, dass da jetzt nix großartig,
optimiert wird, ja. Also,
Sie haben da offensichtlich mal jemanden ans Telefon bekommen, der.
Der weiß was Sache ist und sagte so also irgendeine Umkudierung oder Optimierung oder sonst was äh findet da nicht statt, was ja meine,
ursprüngliche Prothese war in meinem äh naiven, in meiner naiven Leichtgläubigkeit, wenn jemand sagt, wir optimieren etwas, dass ich dachte, ah okay, äh der nimmt das und optimiert das, aber äh machen's einfach nur kaputt. Also.
Jetzt ist es die eigentliche Bedeutung von Optimier.
Sie optimieren das für sich.
Optimieren das in Grund und Boden.
Und dann hatten wir ja in der letzten Sendung ähm gesagt, man man möge doch bitte den äh Soprano's Clusterfuck mal visualisieren.
Das haben äh zwei höhere gemacht, nämlich einmal,
Nelako, das Bild von ihm haben wir auch schon direkt ähm.
In der in den zur Sendung hundertachtundsechzig eingebunden,
und wir haben noch eine zweite Einreichung bekommen, die wir bis jetzt noch nicht veröffentlicht hatten, die kam von Ben, äh und Ben hat das noch so angereichert mit den.
Mit äh Aquarellen von.
Stella, den Nachnamen sage ich jetzt nicht, weil der sehr schwer ist. Ich glaube, er ist fängt mit S an,
Auf, Schiff,
Auf jeden Fall die Stella, die auch äh immer mal wieder bei dem äh Podcast technische Aufklärung zu Gast ist,
die sich immer in den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss setzt und dort Zeichnungen von den,
Insassen äh anfertigt und somit Aquarellfarben auch koloriert, weil man da ja nicht fotografieren darf.
Ähm.
Ich gehe da mal ganz steil voran und sage Stella Shiftschick.
Weil sie das auf ihrer Seite nochmal in Lautschrift stehen hat.
Nö, das steht jetzt hier so im Text, aber das äh ich bin halt mutig, ne? Ja. Bin äh ich gehe voran einfach.
Ja, okay. Mal gucken, ob ob der Ben nach dieser Sendung die Bilder immer noch benutzen.
Da kenne ich einfach kein halten.
Gut, also da haben wir eine Visualisierung und da sieht man äh sehr schön, wie,
so verschiedene Personen wie also halt Klaus-Dieter äh,
Vizepräsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz war, dann Geheimdienstkoordinator, dann Staatssekretär im Innenministerium, dann,
ähm,
zwei Jahre lang gar, also keine keine der aufgezählten Posten und dann eben äh Beauftragter für die Nachrichtendienste im Bundeskanzleramt,
Also das ist echt ganz geil, was dieser bunte Reigen, der da entsteht.
Dass sie so in allen in allen Positionen mal äh rotieren.
Genau, ich denke, da ist visualisierungstechnisch auch noch ein bisschen was zu holen.
Ja genau, also es.
Indem man mehr so den die Verlaufs und Zusammenhangslinien äh äh noch deutlicher macht und vielleicht.
Genau, ich hatte auch vorgeschlagen, man könnte das jetzt so mit mit HTML fünf oder so, dass man.
Quasi wechseln kann jetzt haben wir halt die Linien.
Es ist gerne interaktiv.
Ja unter also Multimedia auf jeden Fall.
Genau, surfen,
filmen durch die Welt mit Multi Media.
Genau, wir haben auf jeden Fall verschiedene äh oder wir haben zwei Visualisierungen, wenn die auch,
herzlich für diese Beiträge, die wir da erhalten haben und das ist tatsächlich sehr schön in beiden dargestellt.
So, das bringt uns zu unserem Hauptthema heute.
Genau.
Das Hauptthema ist äh.
Birgt sich hinter dem kurzen, kryptischen ähm äh Kürzel P N R, das steht für Passenger Name Records, heißt aber eigentlich,
besser, also gemeint sind natürlich die Daten, die anfallen,
Ähm die gespeichert werden müssen über die Passagiere,
von äh Flugzeugen des zivilen Luftverkehrs, des Linienverkehrs, wo halt äh drinsteht, wer fliegt hier? Wo kommt der her? Äh wo wir da hin,
Was für ein äh na, Nationalität ist am Start und natürlich ganz wichtig, äh was für ein Essen wurde bestellt.
Ähm Alexander, vielleicht kannst du mal so ein bisschen deine Perspektive da,
dem Thema ausrollen, was ist da eigentlich bisher,
gelaufen. Das Thema ist ja nicht neu, sondern das wollte uns jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen länger,
und ähm erzähl doch mal, warum ihr da so aktiv seid und was.
Ja, im im Busch ist eine Abstimmung Anfang Februar. Ähm,
Aber vielleicht vorweg nochmal, also diese PNA sind erstmal grundsätzlich Reisedaten und werden tatsächlich nicht nur von Airlines, sondern von so ziemlich allen, die irgendwas mit Reisen zu tun haben, gesammelt. Äh das können zum Beispiel auch,
eben Mietwagen sein oder wenn wir mit dem Schiff oder mit dem Bus unterwegs ist, werden eben auch solche
Reisedaten gesammelt und nach den,
Angriffen auf das World Trade Center damals, ihr äh mit Flugzeugen passiert sind, sind die Amerikaner auf die Idee gekommen, den Flugverkehr besser überwachen zu wollen,
und ähm haben da eben herausgefunden, dass er eben diese Airlines extrem viele Daten sammeln. Ähm du hast schon einige Informationen angesprochen, also bis zu sechzig Einzeldaten werden pro Passagier und pro Flug gesammelt,
sechzig Einzeldaten, ja?
Was ist das sonst noch so?
Ja, das ist zum Beispiel auch der gesundheitliche Zustand von Reisenden, also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Hilfe brauchen äh beim Ein- oder Aussteigen, wenn Kinder unterwegs sind
Daten oder wie man sonst so bezahlt hat, mit wem man noch äh unterwegs ist, also ob man mit jemandem zusammenreist,
wer neben einen sitzt, also Sitzplatzinformationen, wo man selbst sitzt, wer neben einem sitzt, da kommt eine ganze Menge zusammen am Ende,
wie wie schwer ist mein Gepäck? Ähm wie viel Gepäckstücke habe ich dabei? Also all so ein Kram, alles was man was man sich auch nur in Ansätzen vorstellen kann, was mit einer,
verbunden ist, wird da eben gesammelt und gespeichert und äh das Interessante ist, es gibt auch ein Freifeld,
wo dann äh auch noch alles mögliche eingetragen werden kann von,
also wenn ich jetzt zum Check-In laufe und da halt zum Beispiel ähm mich furchtbar aufrege, weil irgendwas Blödes passiert ist,
besteht für die Leute da auch die Möglichkeit in ein Freifeld einzutragen, dass ich zum Beispiel ein aggressiver Gast bin oder was auch immer,
es gab da mal Anfragen aus Amerika, ist auch einer, der es schon sehr sehr lange mit diesem Thema befasst, der hat mal seine PNA-Daten angefragt und hat dann zum Beispiel herausgefunden, dass dann,
in diesem Freifeld zum Beispiel steht, dass er äh ein ein Apfel mit dabei gehabt hat,
Es war offensichtlich eine furchtbar relevante Information,
dann äh eben da gespeichert werden musste, ein Apfel, ne.
Warum auch immer, ja? Ein Apfel ist ähm erwähnenswert.
Also kein MacBook, sondern mhm.
Nein, ein richtiger Apfel. Zum Essen, nicht wahr? Und ähm oder ein anderer war unterwegs mit einem mit einem Buch über Drogenaufklärung. Auch das hat dann eben Einzug gefunden in die PNA-Daten,
Und äh das Problem ist auch grundsätzlich, dass es keine Excess Locks gibt. Also man weiß gar nicht so genau, wer jetzt wann, warum irgendwelche Informationen da einträgt,
oder irgendwo diese PNA-Daten verändert. Ähm man kann das nicht nachvollziehen, wann das,
passiert ist, von wem das passiert ist, also es ist eine relativ ähm ja,
in der jeder, der so ein bisschen sich damit auskennt und vielleicht ein Reisebüro betreibt, dadrin umfuchteln kann,
und eben entsprechende Änderungen äh vornehmen kann. Nichtsdestotrotz, also diese sechzig Einzeldaten, die da eben gesammelt werden oder bis zu sechzig Einzeldaten ähm.
Sollen dann eben genutzt werden, um im Kampf gegen Terrorismus ähm ja
ähm effektiver und effizienter arbeiten zu können. Das waren dann eben die Amerikaner, die da die damit angefangen haben. Ähm vor allen Dingen eben ähm,
und ähm daraufhin sind dann die Airlines äh ein bisschen auf die Barrikaden gegangen, haben gesagt, ja, wir wissen gar nicht, ob das jetzt halt ähm also vor allen Dingen europäische Airlines, ja. Ob das mit mit unseren datenschutzrecht vereinbar ist, wenn wir euch jetzt diese Daten geben,
Daraufhin hat man das gemacht, was man im transatlantischen Beziehungen sehr gerne macht. Man ähm versucht das Ganze zu legalisieren. Also man hat dann eben ein Abkommen auf den Weg gebracht
Ähm zwischen den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und der Europäischen Union.
Wo man sich darauf verständigt hat, dass eben diese Fluggastdaten,
offiziell an die Amerikaner weitergegeben werden dürfen von den Airlines,
und ähm dort für fünfzehn Jahre gespeichert werden. Ähm das war,
Das Ganze hat äh, ich glaube, so zweitausendvier, zweitausendfünf waren das, also, ist schon auf jeden Fall ein bisschen länger her. Ähm, angefangen
dann wurden da noch äh zwei, drei andere Abkommen auf den Weg gebracht, weil das erste war irgendwie nicht richtig verhandelt und mit hin und her, also hat man sich dann ähm in ich glaube.
Zehn war das, ähm hat man dann endlich ein ein korrektes Abkommen auf den Weg gebracht, eben mit,
fünfzehnjährigen Vorratsdatenspeicherung eben dieser Reisedaten.
Fünfzehn.
Fünfzehn Jahre genau, ne. Ähm,
wurden dann auch noch Abkommen mit ähm Kanada und Australien verhandelt,
Australien hat fünfeinhalb Jahre Speicherdauer, Kanada fünf Jahre, also,
und ähm man hat eben auch in der Vergangenheit überhaupt keinen Beweis dafür geliefert, dass diese Datenauswertung,
und richtig ist. Nichtsdestotrotz ist man dann eben ähm in der EU auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, wenn man diese Daten ja an die Amerikaner weitergibt,
sollten wir so ein System auch selber aufbauen. Das Ganze nennt man dann eben EU-PNR,
Anfang war die Idee zu sagen, alle Flüge, die in die EU hineingehen und alle Flüge, die aus der EU herausgehen werden überwacht,
Mittlerweile ist man sogar so weit, dass man eben auch innereurop,
in eine staatliche Flüge überwachen will, also das Ganze wurde dann eben in diesen Diskussionen und Verhandlungen noch weiter ausgeweitet,
und äh genau über diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die jetzt dann auch für fünf Jahre angelegt ist, also fünf Jahre Speicherdauer wird jetzt in der ersten Februarwoche im EU-Parlament abgestimmt und ähm da ist das Thema für uns jetzt gerade relevant und wichtig.
Welcher Ausschuss äh beschäftigt sich damit?
Das ist der Innenausschuss des EU Parlaments, also die ähm auch die Datenschutzreform zum Beispiel verhandelt haben,
die beschäftigen sich eben auch seit zweitausendelf mit dem Thema. Zweitausendelf hat ja die EU Kommission einen,
Vorschlag vorgelegt
zweitausenddreizehn witzigerweise hat genau dieser Ausschuss gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt, hat gesagt, dass es hier gegen europäische Grundrechte verstößt mit.
Die normale VDS.
Reisedaten.
Okay, gegen Penner schon, okay. Mhm.
Rahmen welches Prozesses haben die dagegen äh gestimmt, also was stand,
an der gab's dann auch schon einen Vorschlag von von der Kommission.
Genau, genau, also zweitausendelf kam dieser Vorschlag von der Kommission, dann geht das ja in Rat und Parlament.
Genau und das Parlament.
Sozusagen erstmal nicht mehr offiziell was.
Dagegen gestimmt.
Dagegen gestimmt gegen diesen Vorschlag der Kommission. Also es gab halt Änderungsanträge, um das entweder auszuweiten oder ein bisschen zu reduzieren.
Aber im Wesentlichen sozusagen die Negierung der, der, der, der Kernziele. Und jetzt kommt es sozusagen nochmal.
Und dann ist ja der, also der Prozess ist ja, es ist erst im Ausschuss und wird dann ans Plenum übermittelt, wo dann alle Abgeordneten nochmal drüber,
und äh nachdem dieser Innenausschuss dagegen abgestimmt hatte.
Haben vor allen Dingen die Konservativen nicht damit gerechnet, dass äh sich dann doch eine Mehrheit dafür findet. Ähm.
Gab's ein großes Bohei und äh viel Diskussion und äh Fraktionssitzung und was machen wir jetzt mit der Abstimmung im Liba-Ausschuss? Ähm damit hat keiner gerechnet. Also Liebeausschuss ist eben dieser Innenausschuss. Und ähm daraufhin hat man dann im Plenum,
Zwei Monate später entschieden, wir geben das wieder zurück an den Ausschuss. Die sollen dann nochmal drüber nachdenken. Ob die Entscheidung, die sie da getroffen hat, tatsächlich der Wahrheit entspricht,
ja? Also hat man dann das Ganze sozusagen nochmal verschoben, vertagt,
und jetzt hat der Innenausschuss nochmal zwei Jahre lang dadrüber nachgedacht, hat äh
bisschen diskutiert und äh hat festgestellt, also wir müssen das äh nicht nur zustimmen, sondern wir müssen das auch noch ausweiten. Ja, also das ist äh,
so so geht's nicht, hat sich dann also sozusagen,
innereuropäische Flüge überwacht werden können. Das war vorher äh gar nicht so vorgesehen,
und ähm dieser Kompromiss wurde jetzt auch im Dezember nochmal im Innenausschuss im Liegeausschuss abgestimmt. Da gab's eben eine Mehrheit und jetzt geht es,
wieder ins Plenum
und ähm wird eben dann am in der ersten Februarwoche von allen EU-Abgeordneten dann nochmal abgestimmt,
theoretisch ist es auch möglich, da noch mal Änderungsanträge einzubringen, was allerdings unwahrscheinlich ist, nach dem Trilog, weil dann meistens halt eben dieser Kompromiss zwischen
im Parlament schon gefunden ist und man das nicht nochmal aufbauen will.
Das ist ja eine sehr, sehr ungewöhnliche Konstellation. Das A, das Plenum jetzt einerseits dem dem Ausschuss nicht folgt. Das ist ja schon.
Eher selten und dass dann sozusagen das jetzt sozusagen so lange nochmal weiter beraten wird, bis bis wirklich der der Ausschuss eine komplette andere Richtung hat. Müssen wir mal kurz darüber nachdenken. Zweitausendelf sagst du,
Wann waren denn jetzt nochmal die EU-Wahlen? Also haben wir da zwischendurch.
Wir hatten zwischendurch eine EU-Wahl, ja.
Wir hatten da sozusagen eine Parlamentsänderung. Das heißt, das hat's in der Legislaturperiode dann nicht mehr geschafft und dann mit der neuen Bestückung
einer neuen Zusammensetzung. Und was hat sich äh hast du irgendwie einen Eindruck? Äh was genau an dieser Zusammensetzung dieses Ausschusses dazu geführt haben
also gab's da jetzt irgendwie eine Verschiebung in der Parteienlandschaft oder andere.
Also ich glaube, dass.
Ist es noch der selbe Berichterstatter.
Es ist noch derselbe Berichterstatter. Das ist ähm Timothy,
Ultrakonservative hat auch mal,
britischen Innenministerium eine Zeit lang gewerkelt und ist so absoluter Hardliner und äh großer Freund,
wurde, also ohne ihn wäre es sichtlich ein bisschen schwieriger geworden.
Aber der war auch schon bei der ersten.
Der war, der war bei der ersten Entscheidung mit dabei und es ist also vor allen Dingen eben ähm.
Am bei der ersten Abstimmung im Innenausschuss haben auch Konservativen mit dagegen gestimmt, also es,
auch konservative Abgeordnete, die gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt haben,
Es gab damals so zweitausenddreizehn auch so eine Stimmung, ähm ja, wir bringen immer mehr Überwachungsgesetze auf den Weg. Die kosten auch alle Geld.
Wir haben jetzt grad alle nicht so viel Geld, Wirtschaftskrise hin und her und mit Terrorismus haben wir auch momentan nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun, also,
war das so 'ne Stimmung die eigentlich so dazu geführt hat dass auch einige Konservative tatsächlich gesagt haben jetzt reicht's erstmal, jetzt wollen wir erstmal wissen was mit den bestehenden Maßnahmen so möglich ist,
aber ähm.
Jetzt läuft die Wirtschaft wieder ein bisschen und mehr Terror.
Ein bisschen genauer und dann sind halt die Konservativen dann auch ich nehme an, dass die auch in der Fraktionssitzung dann halt nochmal ein bisschen Feuer bekommen haben,
und natürlich auch die Sozialdemokraten, die dann halt auch immer ein bisschen das Zünglein an der Waage sind, die dann jetzt eben auch umgekippt sind. Also an der an der grundsätzlichen Konstellation im Ausschuss hat sich gar nicht so sehr viel geändert,
hat und vor allen Dingen die Mitgliedsstaaten, die Innenminister, die haben halt Druck gemacht über die Jahre hinweg,
an die Terrorbeauftragte der EU und sowas, also es kam halt die ganze Zeit von allen Seiten ähm sozusagen Druck auf, auf den Innenausschuss, so dass ähm ja dann dieser dann auch eingeknickt ist und ähm,
dann im Dezember halt für die Einführung dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt hat.
Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du das das Parlament dann wiederum äh dem Vorschlag,
Innenausschusses nicht folgen möchte und vielleicht diesmal in die andere Richtung marschiert.
Ja, das kommt drauf an, was wir in den nächsten, der, was wir was wir in den nächsten zwei Wochen hier noch auf die Beine gestellt bekommen, aber es wird auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr schwer. Da eine eine Mehrheit zu finden, die die sich dagegen ausspricht, eher unwahrscheinlich tatsächlich.
Gibt's denn überhaupt Fraktionen, die da sich klar positioniert haben gegen so eine Verschärfung?
Ja, das sind halt die üblichen Verdächtigen, ne, so die Grünen, die Linken, die werden auf jeden Fall dagegen stimmen. Es wird,
ein paar Sozialdemokraten geben, die dagegen stimmen. Ähm die österreichische Delegation ist da zum Beispiel immer so eine relativ standhafte Bank,
da hoffen wir natürlich auch, dass die dagegen stimmen. Es wäre natürlich auch schön, wenn die deutschen Sozialdemokraten gegen diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung stimmen,
Schauen wir mal, wie die sich da positionieren werden. Ähm.
Na die sind ja immer sehr prinzipientreu unterwegs.
Absolut, ja. Ja, sind, das sind die besten.
Fragt sich nur gerade, was.
Ja
Des Tages ist.
Ja. Ähm ein paar liberale werden auf jeden Fall auch dagegen stimmen so. Also das ist das im EU Parlament gibt's ja auch nicht so diesen diesen ganz ernsthaften Fraktionszwang,
da werden ja immer so ein paar Ausreißer geduldet und erlaubt. Ähm von daher ähm der,
es schon Leute geben, die dagegen stimmen, ähm ob's jetzt wirklich die breite Mehrheit ist, ähm wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Wie organisiert ihr jetzt sozusagen die nächsten zwei Wochen? Was sind eure Aktivitätsziele?
Wir haben auch im Vorfeld schon einige so kleinere Kampagnenideen auf den Weg gebracht. Wir haben zum Beispiel gemeinsam mit,
gedruckt, den wir dann halt an EU-Abgeordnete verteilt haben. Wir haben auch ähm nochmal speziell Deutsche Postkarten, die wir an deutsche Abgeordnete verteilt haben,
da steht dann auch hinten nochmal so ein kleiner Text drauf was blöd ist und warum die Abgeordneten dagegen stimmen sollen
Ähm wir rufen an, wir schicken E-Mails, wir versuchen mit den Abgeordneten in Kontakt zu kommen. Das ist natürlich auch was, was ähm die Leute da draußen gerne tun können. Ähm
doch ähm meist überrascht und äh merken, dass sich die Leute dafür interessieren, das ist auf jeden Fall,
und ähm was wir jetzt noch äh ins Leben gerufen haben, ist so eine kleine,
eine kleine Videoaktion, dass die,
Leute vielleicht ein Ein-Minuten-Video einfach machen ähm und da konkret EU-Abgeordnete eben dazu auffordern, dagegen zu stimmen, dass wir mit einem Hashtag und einfach an die Leute über soziale Netzwerke direkt schicken,
dass einfach vor allen Dingen die Urabgeordneten merken, dass eben Leute da draußen sind, die sich für das Thema interessieren, die mit,
kommen, dass da Entscheidungen getroffen werden und die diese Entscheidung auch genau verfolgen,
und ähm ja, dann vielleicht auch bei der nächsten Wahl überlegen.
Ähm was war denn damals bei der Einführung von Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähm wie hat sich denn da meine Urabgeordnete oder meine EU-Abgeordnete verhalten und dann möglicherweise das auch Einfluss eben auf das Wahlergebnis haben kann. Also wir wollen einfach vor allen Dingen die politischen Kosten halt hochtreiben.
Hm. Ähm.
Vielleicht können wir nochmal ein bisschen auf die Daten eingehen. Soll da auch gespeichert werden, wann ich wohin geflogen bin?
Genau, also es wird ähm vierundzwanzig Stunden achtundvierzig bis vierundzwanzig Stunden,
bevor ein Flugzeug startet, werden die Daten an Ermittlungsbehörden übermittelt, wer alles im Flug gebucht hat,
was da schon für Daten im Vorfeld sozusagen gesammelt wurden und dann wird nochmal in dem Moment, wo
ähm das Boarding ähm abgeschlossen ist, die Türen zu sind und keiner mehr raus und rein kann,
wird dieser Datensatz nochmal übermittelt, ähm sodass eben klar ist, wer sitzt jetzt am Ende des Tages,
wo genau in dem Flugzeug und äh ist in welcher gesundheitlichen Verfassung hat wie viel Gepäck dabei und ist äh welches Essen und ähm,
dieser Datensatz wird dann einmal komplett ähm übermittelt. Also man weiß, wer, wann, wohin fliegt und ähm und das weiß man schon im Vorfeld.
Und der wird aufbewahrt für wie lange? Fünf Jahre.
Fünf Jahre, also es gibt äh eine ähm Speicherdauer dann im Vorfeld nochmal für ein halbes Jahr, wo ähm.
Auf den Datensatz zugegriffen wird,
Durch diese Ermittlungsbehörden, also wo mit mit ähm mit Namen, personenbezogenen Daten gearbeitet werden kann
Nach einem halben Jahr ähm werden die Daten die personalisiert äh auch eine ganz witzige Sache zur zur Historie vielleicht am am Anfang wollte man
die Daten anonymisieren und später de anonymisieren. Das ist ein,
interessanter Vorgang, wie man anonym sieht, der Daten wieder de anonymisieren kann,
Ähm das hat man dann irgendwie festgestellt, dass das irgendwie wahrscheinlich doch nicht so gut funktioniert und deswegen hat man sich jetzt für das, für den Begriff die personalisieren entschieden. Ähm,
und ähm,
Diese Daten bleiben dann eben für viereinhalb Jahre lang noch mal in so einer, ja sagen wir mal, in vergleichsweise ruhenden Datenbank.
Dürfen eben nur depersonalisiert werden, wenn eben ein konkreter Terrorverdacht,
vorliegt. Die Daten werden aber trotzdem noch eben für Profiling-Maßnahmen,
genutzt. Ähm das Ganze wird so formuliert in dem, in dem Vorschlag der EU-Kommission, dass diese Daten genutzt werden, um bisher unbekannte Verdächtige
man macht eben Data-Mining, Profiling mit diesen mit diesen Daten und versucht dann eben ähm,
mit viel Datenschüttelei, irgendwie Verdächtige zu kreieren und sie sich dann,
genauer anzugucken, dass es sozusagen der Plan und wenn man dann da jemanden identifiziert hat,
der möglicherweise in dieser runden Datenbank schon ist, also nach einem halben Jahr schon sozusagen aussortiert wurde, dann werden die Daten wieder depersonalisiert und man kann eben genau gucken, was dieser Mensch halt so äh für Gepäck mit dabei gehabt hat. Also vor vier Jahren,
von Frankfurt nach München geflogen ist.
Gibt's denn in irgendeiner Form im Rahmen dieser ähm,
Diskussion im Innenausschuss,
oder auch bei der Kommission, also in irgendeiner Form an der Stelle, wo über Änderungen diskutiert wird, auch,
konkrete Bedenken im Hinblick auf diese Anonymisierung, also,
gibt's gibt's irgendwelche abfedernden Aspekte, die da überhaupt noch mit drin sind? Oder ist der derzeitige,
Beschluss eher so mit, wir speichern alles, wir werten alles aus, wir speichern es ewig und äh seid mal ruhig, weil wir müssen ja hier was gegen Terror tun oder sind da irgendwelche Abwägungen drin?
Also es gibt äh es
Zum einen gibt's ähm Vorgaben, wann diese Daten gespeichert und ausgewertet werden dürfen. Ähm das ist nämlich zum einen,
und zum anderen schwere Kriminalität. Und diese schwere Kriminalität ist da nochmal abschließend definiert,
Ähm darunter ist dann sowas wie Cyberkriminalität, ähm was auch immer das dann halt ist, äh.
Tastaturbenutzung.
Autoschieberei, Autoheelereis äh als schwere Straftat mit dabei. Ähm,
Also es gibt so ein paar Kriminalitätsfelder, wo man sich schon fragt, wo jetzt hier der,
Der so schwerwiegende äh sozusagen Eingriff ähm gerechtfertigt werden kann. Ähm ich glaube, so bei Autoschieberei ist wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht mit mit ähm eine Bedrohung von Leib und Leben einer gesamten Gesellschaft in in jedem Moment zu rechnen,
dass dass sowas dann eben mit aufgeführt wird kann einen schon bedenklich stimmen, also insgesamt sind das fünfundzwanzig,
Kategorien, glaube ich, fünfundzwanzig oder siebenundzwanzig ähm,
und es gibt natürlich auch ähm sehr weitreichende Datenschutz äh Mechanismen, die da eingebaut wurden, um das Ganze halt sehr, sehr sicher zu machen. Es ist nämlich so, dass ja keine sensiblen Daten ausgewertet werden dürfen,
also zum Beispiel Religionszugehörigkeit oder sowas darf nicht Teil dieser Auswertung sein. Jetzt ist es.
Erfasst.
Ähm das das interessant, ja das kann grundsätzlich erfasst werden. Wie gesagt.
Aber nicht nicht als standardisierter Rekord, das steht da nicht drin jetzt.
Nee, nee, es gibt jetzt gibt kein standardisierten, aber es gibt zum Beispiel eben dieses Freifeld, wo man eintragen könnte, weiß ich nicht, ähm sieht, sieht, sieht aus wie, weiß ich nicht, äh genau.
Fleisch essen. Mhm.
Sieht aus wie gläubig oder was weiß ich. Also man kann eben ähm
bestimmte sensible Daten dürfen angeblich nicht verwendet werden. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass die Airlines das ja erstmal alles speichern. Und die Airline selbst weiß ja jetzt gar nicht so genau, was jetzt ein sensible Information ist oder nicht. Schickt das also erstmal diesen kompletten Datensatz an die Ermittlungsbehörden
und dann sitzen die Ermittlungsbehörden da und überlegen, was jetzt eine sensible Information ist und dann halt möglicherweise aus dem Datensatz gelöscht werden muss,
das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man Hund auf eine Wurst aufpassen lässt man hat da schon eben auch Erfahrung zum Beispiel,
Australien gemacht, die haben das versucht, so ein bisschen zu automatisieren diesen Prozess,
haben aber eben festgestellt, dass mit dem Freifeld einfach ein riesengroßes,
aufgetreten ist, weil sie einfach wirklich jeden Datensatz sich händisch angucken müssen,
um herauszufinden, ob da jetzt eben sensible Informationen mit dabei sind oder nicht. Wenn wir jetzt ähm eine ungefähre Vorstellung davon hat, wie viele Flügel so äh tagtäglich,
jetzt sensible Informationen drin sind oder nicht, kann man da durchaus daran zweifeln, ob diese,
tatsächlich auch aussortiert werden.
Ja, ich denke, die rufen dann Herrn Graulich an und der setzt sich da in den Keller und äh blättert da äh das alles durch.
Das wird so sein, der wird sich sicherlich ärgern, ob der zehn Minuten, die er jetzt länger am Tag arbeiten muss,
noch, also vielleicht um das noch ganz kurz zu Ende zu führen. Es gibt noch weitere interessante Datenschutzmechanismen, die da eingebaut wurden,
und hier ist äh ganz witzig, dass äh Europol hat ja einen Datenschutzbeauftrag,
Datenschutzbeauftragte von Europol wird von dem äh von dem Verwaltungsrat,
auf Vorschlag des Direktors ernannt. Und dieser Datenschutzbeauftragte bei Europol ist dann eben auch informiert.
Darüber, äh wenn ein Daten ähm Satz an Euro pro geschickt wurde und dort ausgewertet wird. Also es steht A nur drinne, dass dieser informiert wird, also es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeiten für diesen Datenschutzbeauftragten von Europol da in irgendeiner Art und Weise zu intervenieren,
ausschließlich interveniert ausschließlich informiert und darüber hinaus, wie gesagt, also wie diese Figur da überhaupt erstmal Datenschutzbeauftragte wird, so kann man auch eben,
durchaus mal hinterfragen, ob der dann tatsächlich Datenschutz,
sich wirklich auf die Fahnen schreib.
Ja. Umfeld nochmal etwas klarer zu machen, wohin die Daten zu welchem Zeitpunkt gehen. Also ich kaufe mir ein Ticket,
Da fallen ja schon mal Daten an, weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen schon Teil dieser Speicherung ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt, kann sein, wahrscheinlich ja.
Spätestens, wenn ich einchecke, ist ja sozusagen der Fakt,
will da jetzt mitfliegen auch erfasst. Ähm.
Dann sitze ich im Flugzeug. Ist das der Zeitpunkt? Also,
ist ja dieser soll ja dieser Datensatz in gewisser Hinsicht schon verfügbar sein. Das war ja insbesondere der Wunsch der Amerikaner, dass da sozusagen am besten gar nicht erst jemand auch nur ins Flugzeug gelassen wird, der, der äh was machen könnte, richtig?
Zwischen vierundzwanzig und achtundvierzig Stunden im Vorfeld müssen die Daten äh übermittelt werden, also,
das nennt sich die werden jetzt aufgebaut. Jedes Mitgliedsstaat soll äh,
so eine persönliche Information aufbauen, das sind eben die, an die diese Daten übermittelt werden und eben
vierundzwanzig Stunden Minimum pur Abflug werden diese Daten an diese persönliche Information geschickt und dann nochmal.
Benni aktualisiert, wenn ich eben äh tatsächlich im Flugzeug sitze, die Tür zu mache und keine mehr raus und reingeht. Dann werden die Daten nochmal geschickt. Also.
Also wenn jemand umgebucht wird und so was, das passiert.
Okay, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Tür zugeht, so und was ist das für eine Organisation, diese was hast du gerade gesagt?
Passenger Information heißt das.
Okay und wer betreibt die dann? Oder soll betreiben? Die gibt's derzeit noch nicht so, ne?
Die werden aufgebaut, also wenn dieses äh,
wird, dann sind die Mitgliedsstaaten verpflichtet, solche Units aufzubauen,
und ähm die können sie ansiedeln, wo sie wollen. Also jeder Mitgliedsstaat sozusagen ernennt dann halt irgendwie mehr oder weniger irgendeine Behörde, die dann damit beauftragt wird,
so eine Unit aufzubauen, da gibt's dann halt eben noch so ein paar Vorgaben, so vom ähm äh Datensicherheit und und so was, also dass da.
Könnte beim Innenministerium landen, könnte beim Geheimdienst landen, könnte bei der.
Könnt ihr überall irgendwo, also die, die.
Keine Vorgabe so.
Nö, nö, nö, also nach dem geltenden nationalen Recht, einfach,
der also dem die Mitgliedsstaaten sind dann halt einfach selbst damit beschäftigt, so ein Ding da hochzuziehen.
Ist eigentlich schon mal interessant, ne, dass an der Stelle auch noch nicht mal so in Richtlinie ist das eine Richtlinie eigentlich? Ja, ne?
Richtlinie genommen, ja.
Gibt's diese Informationsstellen, die sammeln die sozusagen erstmal so als Proxi ein oder sind das,
Also sind ihnen dann nur zu einem,
Es geht's da drum, die zentral zu speichern, gibt's dann auf EU-Ebene nochmal eine zentrale Sammelstelle oder verbleibt das erstmal äh in.
Also das ist also das ist total interessant gebaut, also das jede jede Mitgliedstaat baut eben so ein Ding dann da auf, wo die Daten hingeschickt werden und dann tauschen die innerhalb
äh dann nochmal die Daten aus. Also wenn ich jetzt von von Spanien nach Deutschland fliege, werden die Daten,
Spanien einmal nach Deutschland geschickt und die wirfen die Daten auch nochmal untereinander sozusagen, gucken die nochmal, ob das alles passt,
dann kommt zum Beispiel irgendwann ein Brite um die Ecke und sagt, hier wir haben äh weiß ich nicht, irgendjemanden unter Terrorverdacht und dann fragen die alle siebenundzwanzig
äh anderen Mitgliedsstaaten habt ihr da mal irgendwann bei euch in der im im in der Datenwürfellei so einen Typ, der mit dabei gehabt und dann schicken
diese persönliche Information dann diese Daten eben an den Anfragen, Mitgliedsstaat. Also es ist die ganze Zeit so ein riesengroßer Datenaustausch, der da stattfindet zwischen diesen.
Aber von separaten Identitäten immer auf Basis von expliziten Anfragen ist es jetzt noch nicht soweit.
Da ein Verbundenes hat, wo jeder jede Datenbank jederzeit anfragen.
Gibt's Euro pro, die dann halt auch äh in diesen Datensätzen noch mit rumwühlen können.
Okay, aber Europol kriegt auch immer eine Kopie.
Müssen anfragen und Europol wird also diese die sitzen da,
bekommen diesen Datensatz, machen ein bisschen Detailing, bisschen Profiling, schütteln die Daten bisschen und stellen dann fest, oh hier ist jemand, äh der uns irgendwie auffällig erscheint. Dann sind die grundsätzlich verpflichtet, diese Informationen an alle anderen weiterzugeben, unter anderem eben auch an Europol.
So ein gewisser Level an Auffälligkeit sozusagen erreicht ist. Mhm.
Und äh um damit dann eben nicht nur technische Maßnahmen greifen, muss ich dann auch nochmal ein Mensch,
Ergebnis angucken, ne, ist auch große Schutzmechanismus und dann werden diese Daten, diese Ergebnisse mit anderen Mitgliedsstaaten geteilt.
Diese Daten weitergegeben und eben äh auch an Europol. Also es ist einfach ein riesengroßer,
glaube ich, also ich ich stelle mir das auch ziemlich kompliziert vor, dass äh sozusagen dann halt dieser Austausch auch wirklich gut funktioniert, weil das äh wirkt schon per se erstmal so, als müsste er eigentlich ziemlich viel schiefgehen halt,
Aber das wird man dann halt eben sehen, wie wie gut das funktioniert. Ich ähm habe da grundsätzlich sowieso Zweifel, ob dieses,
Auswerten von Fluggastdaten in irgendeiner Art und Weise halt äh zu zu irgendwas,
tragen kann, außer dass man halt eben tatsächlich neue Verdächtige kreiert, bei dem man dann feststellt, dass sie ja doch eigentlich gar nichts mit Terrorismus zu tun haben.
Wer eure Kritik ist ja im Prinzip des Missbrauchspotential, weil es sich ja hier letztlich auch nur um eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh handelt, wenn jetzt auch mit einer anderen Ausrichtung und Ansiedlung
Ich denke, was auch noch so ein bisschen im Raum steht, ist so diese generelle Angst, dass in dem Moment, wo das für Flugdaten mal eingeführt ist, dass wir da nicht mehr lange brauchen, bis wir das dann auch für
keine Ahnung, Mautstrecken et cetera auch haben.
Ja, also es gibt da schon vor allen Dingen die Briten,
sehr forsch voran und wollen das eben sehr gerne auch noch ausweiten. Vor allen Dingen eben auf Züge und Schiffe,
und wenn man sich eben anschaut wie jetzt schon alleine in diesen fünfjährigen Verhandlungs,
Ist, glaube ich, relativ klar, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist nämlich zu einer total Überwachung des Reiseverkehrs kommt,
und hier einfach versucht wird, sämtliche Informationen einzusammeln, die man bekommen kann,
gesagt, diese Daten werden auch von ähm Mietwagenanbietern ähm gesammelt, von Hotels.
Ähm und ähm überall werden solche solche PNA-Daten gesammelt. Ähm also hier gibt's noch sehr, sehr viel Potenzial.
Also sie sind hier so noch nicht Teil dieser Abstimmung, da geht's jetzt wirklich nur ums Flugverkehr, aber man weiß die Daten sind ja da, ne? Mhm. Carsharing.
Weil das kann ja nicht sein, dass und so weiter. Ja.
Terroristen wohnen ja auch gerne in meinem Hotel und dann muss man natürlich da auch wissen, äh was die da so aus einer Minibar rausgeholt haben.
Läuft's. Linus.
Ein Aspekt den du gerne noch äh beleuchten möchtest oder.
Bin seit Jahren.
Das das Tolle ist, das tolle ist.
Deine Daten oder was?
Malten Moor Informationen werden auch nach einem halben Jahr depersonalisiert, ja.
Alle frequentabler Information werden nach einem halben Jahr die personalisiert.
Was heißt denn das? Die personalisiert, bei wem werden sie DPD.
In diese in dieser Passenger Information werden die dann sozusagen also man man hat dann nur noch einen Datensatz vorliegen, der eben keinen Namen mehr beinhaltet und auch eben diese Vielfliegeinformation nicht mehr beinhaltet und
dieser Datensatz wird aber eben trotzdem noch für Profiling verwendet und wenn ich dann nach dem Profiling feststelle, oh der Linos oder also, oh diese mysteriöse Person hier
wir hier jetzt entdeckt haben. Über die wollen wir gern mehr wissen und dann werden zum Beispiel äh eben dann der Name wieder äh sichtbar gemacht und dann wird eben auch die die Vielfliegerinformation wieder sichtbar gemacht.
Also wir nur angezeigt, wenn man's möchte. Genau.
Wenn wenn der Verdacht sich äh erhärtet. Äh ganz interessant ist übrigens, wenn man wenn man sich die die Amis mal anguckt, die ja auch schon sehr viel Erfahrung mit dieser Fluggastdatenauswertung haben und die ja tatsächlich auch diese No-Flight-Orders aussprechen,
Ähm wer da eigentlich so auf diesen No-Flight-Listen ist so, das ist nämlich ganz interessant, da sind hin und wieder auch äh tatsächlich berühmte
Leute drauf, also Nelson Mandela war zum Beispiel mal auf dieser Liste und also am abgefahrensten finde ich eigentlich, dass da immer wieder Kinder.
Werden immer.
Werden immer jünger, werden immer jünger, ja. Und äh wenn man wenn man das sieht, dann weiß man eben, was mit so einer Datenauswertung grundsätzlich möglich ist, nämlich ziemlich viel Käse. Und ähm,
Hinzu kommen eben auch noch die Leute, die man vielleicht äh nicht entdeckt. Also es gibt ja so positiven negativen,
Und ähm wenn da dreijährige Kinder drauf sind, dann ist es auch relativ wahrscheinlich, dass der ein oder andere Terrorist einem durch die Lappen geht bei dieser Datenauswertung, als.
Ja, du weißt doch, wenn auch nur ein Opfer geschützt werden kann, dann.
Alles richtig.
Dann dann das alles, dann war's das alles wert, ja.
Aber das ist ja trotzdem interessant, dass die Amis das schon so lange machen und bisher immer noch nicht bewiesen haben, dass das halt tatsächlich der Fall ist. Also.
Bisschen, bisschen, bisschen schade so. Also, wenn denn das so wäre, ich würd's ja wirklich gern einfach mal wissen, so also dann könnte man das ja mal sagen, hier in dem und im konkreten Fall hat aufgrund der Fluggastdatenauswertung haben wir es geschafft,
einen Terroranschlag zu verhindern. Aber nein.
Ja, ich meine, wir machen ja immer gerne äh die äh die Witze mit dem Heu und,
stehen äh Stecknadeln. War ganz stolz, dass Sascha Loh auch äh,
mein äh ruft nach mehr Heu jetzt äh in seine Kolumne getragen hat. Ähm.
Andererseits wissen wir natürlich auch, dass die ähm,
Deep-Learning und so weiter, lassen ja durchaus auch
Absehen, dass sagen wir mal die potenzielle Informations,
aus solchen Datenmengen
dass sich das auch mal ändern kann, ja? Ich meine, man macht ja immer ganz gerne mal so
sein was wollt ihr denn mit den ganzen Daten? Ihr seid doch eh zu doof da irgendwelche nennenswerten Schlussfolgerungen draus zu ziehen, das ist ja äh in unseren Kreisen auch sehr beliebt, aber ich glaube die sehr viel größere Gefahr liegt dadrin, dass sich das nämlich dann auch mal ändert. Das eben sehr wohl,
Ich mag auch gar nicht ausschließen, dass sowas vielleicht auch mal wirklich zu einer Aufspürung,
Verdächtiger oder vielleicht eben auch konkret gefährlicher Menschen führen kann.
Ja, wobei man ja eben, wie gesagt, grundsätzlich immer so eine Abwägung eben dann ähm bei so einem massiven Grundrechtseingriff halt vornehmen muss und ähm,
solange wie es eben kein Beweis für diesen Nutzen dieser Datensammelwut gibt,
geht's sowieso überhaupt gar nicht, finde ich. Und ähm wenn man dann diesen Beweis erbracht, muss man eben immer noch abwägen und ähm wir haben ja auch das EUGH-Urteil eben zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Kommunikationsdaten und da wird ja auch klar gesagt,
Das ist eigentlich äh überhaupt nicht geht, dass man per se erstmal alle in dem Fall jetzt Flugreisenden äh unter Generalverdacht stellt äh und,
denn was anderes ist es ja nicht, ja? Also die Unschuldsvermutung wird ja komplett außer Kraft,
gehoben. Jeder, jeder Flugreisende wird permanent für fünf Jahre lang wie ein Verdächtiger behandelt.
Weil,
auch da glaube ich, dass die, ich will das jetzt gar nicht schön reden, aber nur mal so auch dieser politischen Argumentation, der anderen Seite ein bisschen folgen zu können,
die das anders sehen, dass die sozusagen dieses, nur weil die Daten da jetzt mal mit untersucht werden und mit in diesen Algorithmus einfließen,
geht da ja noch nicht automatisch einen Verdacht
hervor, im Sinne eines ähm rechtsrelevanten Prozesses, es ist ja nicht so, dass sie,
an deine Tür klopft, nur weil die Daten da jetzt mitprozessiert werden. Das ist äh äh sicherlich nachvollziehbar.
Ähm trotzdem die Frage ist natürlich auch,
und wie viel Zutrauen kann man so einem Algorithmus letzten Endes äh auch äh gewähren, weil in dem Moment, wo dann eben die Lampe aufleuchtet und sagt,
ist gefährlich, weil unser Computer hat das gesagt
sehen wir ja auch schon, wie diese Gläubigkeit in, in, in solche Systeme, weil hat ja schon mal funktioniert oder zumindest haben die Programmierer immer gesagt,
das funktionieren würde und wenn's mal die Lampe leuchtet, dann ist das schon relevant. Das
Das ist dann auch sehr schwer ist.
Sich diesem auch noch in irgendeiner Form zu entziehen. Also dann ist ja sozusagen auch ein Verdacht ausgesprochen, der dann auch wirklich äh konkret wird und und und konkrete Auswirkungen haben kann, dem man fast gar nichts entgegen äh setzen kann.
Und ähm
dann kommen auch tatsächlich solche Maßnahmen, dass dann vielleicht mal jemand vor der Tür steht oder dass Konten eingefroren werden,
also da also wenn man wenn man unter so einem Terrorismusverdacht steht
überzogen die die eben wie gesagt bis hin zu Konten einfrieren keine Bewegungsfreiheit mehr und ähnlichen führen können.
Fly, also nur auf der No-Fly-Liste zu landen, alleine, das schließt einem ja im Prinzip von äh Reisen, Geschäftsbeziehungen, et cetera,
auch nur politische Aktivität eigentlich äh aus, also auch in Europa wäre jetzt was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt nicht mehr fliegen könntest.
Das wäre nicht lustig hier.
Immer noch äh E-Mail und
äh den Zug aber so richtig spannend wäre es nicht. Und wenn es sich dann halt auch noch auf Mietwagen,
Carsharing, Züge und Schiffe auch noch ausdehnt in dem Moment, ist man ja im Prinzip schon.
So ist es ja. Also es ist ein massiver Eingriff äh in die Menschenrechte auch,
Und ähm also wie gesagt, das ist äh man muss glaube ich da tatsächlich einfach dem auch das das EuGH-Urteil sich noch mal zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Kommunikationsdaten äh einfach genau anschauen und ähm das das ist eigentlich so die,
Die die Marschrichtung sozusagen, der, der man auch ein Stück weit folgen sollte, also das Ziel,
gegen Terrorismus vorzugehen und das schwere Kriminalität ist natürlich total logisch und soll natürlich auch verfolgt werden.
Die Maßnahme dafür ist aber gänzlich ungeeignet, weil sie eben unseren,
und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir jetzt nur die Fluggastdatenauswertung haben oder nur die Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Kommunikationsdaten, es gibt ja noch einen Haufen andere Maßnahmen, wie man eben ähm,
ja ermitteln kann und es ist ja auch so, dass äh vor allen Dingen die bei den jüngsten Anschlägen, die wir gesehen haben, auch die die Täter schon im Visier der Ermittlungsbehörden waren,
Folge dessen wäre, wenn wir jetzt mit der Fluggastdatenauswertung wissen, hat der, den wir sowieso schon im Klick haben,
den haben wir jetzt auf einer anderen Ebene auch nochmal im Blick, was dadurch besser gemacht werden soll, verstehe ich auch immer noch nicht so genau. Also es ist so, dass wir mit bestehenden Maßnahmen durchaus schon
effektiv und effizient gegen Terrorismus vorgehen können. Ähm hundertprozentige Sicherheit gibt,
auch nicht. Also wir können jetzt natürlich auch anfangen, einfach alle Menschen einzusperren,
Ja und ähm sozusagen immer nur einen draußen rumlaufen zu lassen, dann wissen wir auch, wer der Terrorist war.
Das kann ja nicht irgendwie die Maßnahme sein am Ende des Tages, ja? Und ähm wir müssen halt natürlich unsere, unsere,
FDGO weiter äh äh stärken und erhalten und mit solchen Maßnahmen tun wir genau das Gegenteil und machen damit ja auch den Terroristen schlussendlich zum Gesetzgeber und das kann nicht das Ergebnis sein.
So, was kann man tun äh wenn man.
Sache jetzt noch unterstützen möchte, insbesondere in den nächsten zwei Wochen, dann geht man zum No P NR Punkt ORG.
Genau oder auf die Seite der. Macht ein kleines Video, schickt das entweder an uns oder hat man hat selber einen YouTube-Account und lädt das dann einfach direkt hoch und,
twittert uns vielleicht auch mit an, dass wir das ähm wissen und dann schicken wir das auch an EU-Abgeordnete weiter. Ähm wie gesagt, EU-Abgeordnete Nerven, anrufen, E-Mails schreiben, Faxe schicken
vielleicht wenn sie nochmal in der Wahlkreiswoche tatsächlich irgendwo unterwegs sind, persönlich ansprechen, wenn man selber irgendwie grad zufällig in Brüssel oder in Straßburg unterwegs ist.
Vielen Dank Alexander erstmal für,
die Ausführung hier zu PNR wollten wir schon immer mal ein bisschen ausführlicher behandeln,
jetzt auch mal gemacht,
Was haben wir denn äh sonst noch auf der Agenda?
Mobilfunküberwachung haben wir.
Mal was ganz anderes.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein so ein Klassiker, der
Standardsituationen der kleinen Anfragen der Linksfraktion, die erkundigen sich in regelmäßigen Abständen nach den Überwachungsmaßnahmen im Mithilfebereich. Ähm das geht, glaube ich, immer so von Andre
Und da haben sie sich nach äh mehreren Maßnahmen erkundigt. Erstens,
die nach der Verwendung der stillen SMS.
Stille SMS. Ähm ich hatte das hier schon öfter mal erklärt, aber der Vollständigkeit halber erkläre ich's nochmal. Das ist eine äh quasi ein.
Standard, den es in der Definition von SMS gibt,
Da gibt es verschiedene SMS-Nachrichten, Typen, über die das,
deren Empfang das Telefon den Nutzer nicht in Kenntnis setzt,
ist es vorgesehen. Ähm die haben,
Unterschiedliche, es gibt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, stille SMS zu schicken. Das eine ist irgendwie einfach Typ null und dann die wird einfach den Empfang wird einfach,
Bestätigt und dann ist gut. Ähm man kann aber auch binäre SMS an die SIM-Karte schicken und damit,
keine sinnvolle Aktion auslösen, aber es gibt also,
ein ein Standard konformes Mobiltelefon wird,
Empfang dem Netz gegenüber bestätigen, aber äh den Nutzern nicht anzeigen. Es gibt auch
Darauf habe ich, glaube ich, auch mehrmals hingewiesen. Ähm,
Möglichkeiten, sein Telefon dazu zu bringen, zumindest zu warnen, dass eine solche SMS gekommen ist,
ähm das äh können die Apps,
Ketchup, Ketchup und ähm Snoops,
an deren Entwicklung ich nicht vollständig unbeteiligt war, weil sie aus einem von einem Team entwickelt wurden, mit dem ich ähm,
zu tun habe.
Immer am Bahnhof gesoffen hast.
Man muss das ja als Disclaimer dazu sagen, wenn das aus der eigenen Schmiede kommt. Ähm.
Und diese warum macht man, warum setzten Straffverfolgungsbehörden die ein? Ähm man würde ja eigentlich meinen, ist völlig ähm,
uninteressant, aber letztendlich ist die Gesetzeslage so,
Dass eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde nicht,
so einfach zum ähm zu einem,
Mobilfunknetz gehen durfte und sagen durfte, sag uns doch mal bitte, äh wo der Nutzer gerade ist.
Das geht zwar auch, auch das habe ich, glaube ich, hier schon öfter erzählt, das Telefon das Mobilfunknetz weiß, wo ihr seid, damit es
eure Transaktionen, über die Zellen abwickeln kann, in denen ihr euch tatsächlich auch befindet, also euer Mobiltelefon, sagt dem Mobilfunknetz auch immer, wo ihr seid, aber auf diese Daten gibt es keinen.
Wann ihr eine äh Transaktion durchgeführt habt,
so eingehende oder ausgehende Nachrichten oder Anrufe oder Internet oder so
und dann natürlich auch, über welche Zelle die abgewickelt wurden. Und was der der quasi der juristische Hack war, den Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdienste da zur Anwendung bringen, ist
Naja, wenn wir die Daten nur kriegen, wenn's eine Transaktion gibt, dann machen wir halt eine Transaktion, also schicken wir stille SMS.
In Zeitabständen, die wir für für richtig halten und am Ende des Monats holen wir uns dann eben die Transaktionsdaten,
dann sieht man in den Transaktionsdaten eben, ja, hat, äh, weiß ich nicht, ein paar hundert SMS bekommen und war zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo er diese SMS bekommen hat, jeweils in diesen Zellen und dann kannst du wieder mappen
wo wo diese Zellen waren, dann kannst du damit quasi Location-Tracking machen, etwas, was eigentlich eben den nicht.
Direkt erlaubt ist.
So und jetzt hat das BKA im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn insgesamt einhundertsechzehntausendneunhundertachtundvierzig stille SMS versendet,
Ähm.
Diese Zahl ist natürlich jetzt halt interessant. So, die Frage ist, mit welcher also die Zahl sagt erstmal nichts aus, weil,
Grob überschlagen, hättest du wenn du die einfach sehr schnell sendest, hättest die auch alle an eine Person schicken können, ja? Ähm,
und sie werden sich halt verschiedene zeitliche Auflösungen für unterschiedliche Zielpersonen gesetzt haben. Man weiß auch nicht, ob sie die einfach rund um die Uhr schicken
bei Interesse, mal gucken, oh, wo war der zu dem Zeitpunkt, war der bei der Demo oder nicht? Ne, also.
Also salopp gesagt, es könnte sein, dass sie hunderttausend Mal bei hunderttausend Leuten einmal wissen wollten, wo die sind, aber es kann auch sein, dass sie bei einer Person hunderttausend Mal wissen wollten, wo die ist.
Irgendwo dazwischen wird, die wird sich die Wahrheit ähm.
Verbergen interessant ist aber im zweiten Halbjahr,
zweitausendvierzehn, also im gleichen Zeitraum ein Jahr vorher, haben sie sechsundzwanzigtausend verschickt. Das heißt, sie haben das,
verfünffacht. Ja, in zwei, im und im ersten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn,
Also hatten sie, haben sie zweiundzwanzigtausend verschickt? Also irgendwas ging echt mal hoch im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn, nämlich sie haben auf einmal fünfmal so viele SMS versendet.
Äh der Verfassungsschutz hat äh.
Er äh hatte der Verfassungsschutz hundertzweiundvierzigtausend verschickt,
Und jetzt im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn nur noch fünfundvierzigtausend. Also irgendwie das BKA hat mehr gemacht, der Verfassungsschutz weniger.
Zoll, Bundesnachrichtendienst und der militärische Abschirmdienst nutzen die auch, geben aber ihre Zahlen nicht raus.
Und alle sagen vor allem auch jetzt nicht, wie viele Personen davon betroffen war.
Wie viele Personen sagen sie nicht? Sie sagen nur, die Gesamtzahl dieser äh dieser SMS und die gesagt, diese diese,
Zahl ist wenig aussagekräftig, aber wenn man jetzt mal,
zu Grunde legt, dass die im Zweifelsfall halbwegs,
Rational mit diesem Ding umgehen und die nicht zu oft verschenken und nicht zu wenig würde ich,
eigentlich eher damit rechnen, dass sie sowas wie ein wie fünf, dreißig oder sechzig Minuten als zeitliche Auflösung nehmen. Ja, also du willst ja, dich interessiert ja nicht unbedingt, wo ist die Person langgefahren, ja?
Ich habe aber auch schon mal im Rahmen einer ähm.
Also ich habe mal Einsicht in solche äh Protokolle bekommen. Da war die zeitliche Auflösung auch so im,
etwas also im Mehr, mehrere Minutenbereich.
Wie sind die räumliche Auflösung? Also ist da jetzt eine Triankulation möglich oder kriegt man im Prinzip nur eine Zelle mit?
Kriegst nur die und die übersetzt im Prinzip erstmal nur in einen in ein hundertzwanzig Grad Winkel abgehend von dem Standort der Antenne.
Mehrere Antennen oder mehrere.
Nee, wenn du also wenn du mehrere solche Messungen hast, ne, dann siehst du natürlich, okay, weil also deshalb interessiert dich unter Umständen vielleicht auch schon ein Weg,
Eine Straße, weil die jetzt von der Einzelmessung nicht weiß, welche welche Straße ist sie jetzt wohl gefahren, aber wenn du halt einfach sage ich mal zwanzig Zellen hast, die entlang der Autobahn stehen, dann kannst du die halt relativ einfach ausmalen. Okay, Person wird jetzt da.
Auf der Butter gefahren sein. Was natürlich auch äh ein Grund sein kann, warum mehr,
SMS gesendet werden, weil sie einfach gesehen haben, wir umso häufiger wir abfragen, umso genauere Tracks können wir daraus äh nachvollziehen. Also von daher, interessante Zahl, schwer zu interpretieren.
Interessanter, also interessanter wird die vor allem, wenn dich, wenn dich Zusammenkünfte von Personen interessieren,
dann kann's natürlich einfach sagen, okay, die sind echt einfach, weißt du?
Aus verschiedenen Richtungen gekommen. Stundenlang zusammengehangen.
Die sind aus verschiedenen Richtungen gekommen und dann war der eine zwei Stunden in dieser E Plus Zelle und der andere zwei Stunden in der Tim-Mobile-Zelle, die daneben steht und dann sind die zum gleichen Zeitpunkt dann wieder aus dem Bereich raus, der eine in die eine und der andere in die andere Richtung, ja?
Ähm.
Stille SMS heißt ich.
Ich habe diese Person, ich will die Person im Auge behalten und ich mache ich verwandle im Prinzip ihr Mobiltelefon, was sie in der Tasche hat, in eine Ortungswanze. Ja, also,
Das ist das, obwohl ich das eigentlich, obwohl die Rechtsprechung mir das im Prinzip nicht erlaubt,
habe ich halt quasi diesen juristischen Hack und äh hole mir am Ende des Monats oder vielleicht sogar früher die Transaktionsrecords, ja? Und missbrauche ähm quasi die,
Telekommunikationsüberwachung zur Location-Überwachung. Spielt ja dann auch nochmal wieder eine Rolle
im Rahmen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo er jetzt auch,
anfallen. Das heißt, da wird's auch nochmal interessant, ob eventuell jetzt die,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht
Letztendlich in der Umsetzung das Ende des Versandes stiller SMS bedeutet, weil der ganze Kram ja ehm mehrere Wochen gespeichert werden soll. Also da weiß ich nicht genau wie die Strafverfolgungsbehörden da in Zukunft agieren werden.
Vermutlich werden sie aber weiterhin stille SMS brauchen.
Weil ja in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch nur gespeichert wird, wenn eine Transaktion anfällt.
So von daher die Behörden werden es sicherlich weitermachen.
Ja nur noch um.
So.
Also die, die Personen, es gibt auch noch, also wie gesagt, das Feld des Location-Tracking ist groß und wenn ich hier kurz ein bisschen Eigenwerbung machen darf unter äh GSM Map Punkt ORG,
kann man sich für für alle Länder auch noch so Berichte anschauen, also brauchst du auch echt jetzt nicht unbedingt,
stille SMS, um herauszufinden, wo sich jemand aufhält. Ja, das geht eleganter.
Ähm kann ich gleich hier auch mal kurz zeigen, wenn wir nicht mehr podcasten. Aber ähm,
Genau, da haben wir, haben wir auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen so Angriffe erklärt. So, die andere Sache ist, Insi-Catcher und der Insi-Catcher ist quasi etwas ein Gerät, das sagt, ich bin.
Ein ich bin dein Mobilfunknetz. Ja und das Telefon authentifiziert sich dann bei diesem,
Weil das Signal stark ist, ja? Also das das Telefon fährt,
die Lande und während es so und kriegt halt die ganze Zeit
Signale von den unterschiedlichen Zellen des Mobilfunknetzes,
einer Zelle nach der anderen an. Und zwar immer bei der, die das äh stärkste Signal hat. Und,
geht im Prinzip hin und sagt, hallo, ich bin eine Zelle von deinem Mobilfunknetz, ich sende dir, wie du merkst, ein sehr starkes Signal und das Telefon sagt, ah super, dann gehe ich doch jetzt mal in diese Zelle.
Jetzt unterscheidet sich das auch wieder nach zwei G, drei G und vier G, ich will da aber nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen. Ähm letztendlich sagt das Telefon hallo, hier bin ich,
Ich darf das, hier ist meine Sim und so weiter, hier sind, hier ist meine lass uns mal hier 'ne Dingensauthentifizierung, das Mobilfunknetz sagt dann, das gefälschte Mobilfunknetz,
kann dann auf unterschiedlichen Wegen reagieren, zum Beispiel kann es sagen, ah wunderbar, alles klar, dann bleib mal hier.
Ähm oder es sagt halt, ja, alles klar, wunderbar, du bist das, äh aber ich nehme dich nicht an, ja?
Kann man auf verschiedene Wegen machen, da hab ich zusammen mit Luka und Deckstar beim Camp,
ein äh einen kleinen Workshop artigen Vortrag zu gehalten im BER Village, äh wo ich nochmal die verschiedenen Typen von ihm sehe. Ähm,
erklärt habe. Aber ein sagt quasi am Ende, der liefert am Ende die Daten folgende ähm im süß,
haben sich bei mir angemeldet. Ähm das heißt, da hast du quasi zu einer Location.
Die Opfer, ja, wird äh gerne mal eingesetzt bei äh.
Bei Demos wird aber zum Beispiel auch, dass es immer die Legende, mit der der Einsatz von von oder die Anschaffung von INCE catchern äh gerechtfertigt wird,
Ja, wir haben ja andauernd äh Selbstmorde, äh die sich irgendwie, die am Telefon sagen, sie bringen sich jetzt um
und dann müssen wir mit dem die orten, weil die sind dann im Wald, im dunklen Wald und dann haben wir quasi so einen Imseketcher mit einer Richtantenne und dann dann catchen wir die und dann mit der Richtantenne gehen wir dann dahin, dass das Signal stärker wird und dann retten wir deren Leben. Das ist so
ernsthaft die die Legende, die du immer wieder hörst, wo die die Polizei dir erzählt, warum sie diese brauchen.
Auf diese Methode schon aus dem Wald gezogen.
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich haben die Selbstmorder äh Ketchup, Ketchup oder Snoops und sehen dann, dass dann ist und schalten ihr Telefon aus. Also ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist doch, ich meine, auf so einen Quatsch braucht man sich da gar nicht einzulassen.
Na ja, vor allem stehen die nicht häufiger auf der Autobahnbrücke, als im Wald.
Die Bundespolizei dreißig Mal.
Das sind ungefähr die Zahlen aus dem äh vorherigen Halbjahr. Und.
Dann ist ja aber im Prinzip der INSE-Katcher.
Komplett uninteressant.
Wenn du dir nämlich über die Funkzellenabfrage Gedanken machst. Das Einzige, was der IMSE-Catcher noch hat, ist, du könntest den jetzt halt so konfigurieren, dass er halt,
sehr viel genauere Auflösung hat
Örtlich, ne? Du weißt einfach, wo der steht, wie stark der sendet
und wer da äh wer da gecatcht wird, da kannst du halt dann nochmal, sage ich mal, genauer sein als jetzt zum Beispiel mit einer Funkzelle, die irgendwo aufm Land steht.
Im Prinzip vor ein paar Jahren so.
Recherchiert und der Öffentlichkeit zugetragen hat, nämlich dass sie.
Verstrafverfolgungsbehörden zum Provider gehen und sagen, ey, Kollege, wir wollen gerne wissen, alle, die sich zu diesem, in diesem Zeitraum in dieser definierten Zelle eingebucht haben.
Und ähm da hat man natürlich so ein ähm.
Mitunter halt viele hundert oder viele tausend Leute, ne? Wir hatten das ähm die zwei großen, interessanten Fälle waren einmal, dass die äh dass das in Dresden bei den Demonstrationen zum.
Spinner da aufmarschieren. Nee, das ist ja das sind ja auch die besorgten Bürger, aber die
Nazis, wo man auch weiß, wo die auch Nazis heißen, glaube ich,
Nee, was sind das immer in Dresden? Das sind dann.
Die gedenken dem Bombenterror oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Die besorgten Bomben
Terroristen oder sowas ist das, wo die dann der Bombardierung Dresdens gedenken, ne, und den Heldentod, den da alle geschoren sind und so. Das ist doch bei im Rahmen dieser Aktion sind ja dann immer große äh,
große Proteste und da hat haben dann die Strafverfolgungsbehörden auch äh Funkzellenabfragen gemacht,
in der kompletten Dresdner Innenstadt und hatten damit einfach mal alle, die bei dieser Demonstration waren. Ja, oder bei beiden, ja,
also konnten einfach mal, haben die haben einfach eine Liste aller Personen, die zu dem Zeitpunkt in Dresden waren,
auch eine sehr, sehr grundrechtschonende Maß.
Aller, aller Personen, die ein Mobiltelefon dabei hatten und äh plus alle Leute, die da zwar waren, aber damit nichts zu tun hatten und oben stehen.
Ja, sie haben einfach eine Liste aller Mobiltelefone aller Mobiltelefon, Identitäten, also es ist ja nicht das Mobiltelefon, sondern eher also es geht ja eher um die Sim, weil die Sim ja gebunden ist an die Telefonnummer und die Telefonnummer wiederum an die Person.
Massenüberwachung. Ähm,
einundvierzig Mal zum Einsatz gekommen,
Von der Bundespolizei und vom Zoll neununddreißig Mal zum Einsatz gekommen im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn. Das heißt insgesamt also,
BKA zwanzig Mal, das heißt ähm hundert Einsätze in.
Hundert Funkzellen abfragen in einem halben Jahr. Ne, dreihundertfünfundsechzig Tage.
Durch zwei gleich hundertzweiundachtzig einhalb in hundertachtzig Tagen,
einhundert Funzellen abfragen. Das heißt schon so ungefähr jeden zweiten Tag.
Ist ja auch eine Menge los, also die da immer wieder Leute auf die Straße.
Na und bei jeder Funktion Abfrage, wie gesagt, da hast du halt, wenn du sowas jetzt hier in Berlin machst, wie sie's damals gemacht haben, als hier dieser äh dieser Frust hier rumgerannt ist und Autos angezündet hat, haben sie auch Funkzellenabfragen gemacht. Wenn das in inner Stadt wie Berlin Master,
Gleichzeitig ähm Hass,
hast du da natürlich auch eine relativ effektive.
Ähm Methode, um eine Person zu ermitteln, ne, also die haben halt im Prinzip einfach,
wenn er so ein Auto gebrannt hat, haben sich kurz die Funkzellendaten geholt, das machst du dreimal, dann bleibt einfach nur eine
eine Identität über die an allen drei Orten waren, ne? Das ist einfach über zufällig nicht mehr zu erklären,
Jeweils nachts eine Person sich in der Stadt aufhält, vor allem wenn du das dann an unterschiedlichen, in unterschiedlichen Stadtteilen machst und so, ne? Das ist halt relativ.
Relativ zügig.
Aber so so richtig aufgeklärt wurde, doch darüber.
Äh ich glaube, sie waren dann irgendwie nicht klug genug, das richtig auszuwerten. Am Ende haben sie den irgendwie, glaube ich, über eine Überwachungskamera oder sowas gefunden, aber der die Funkzellenabfrage hatte auch eine Rolle gespielt. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist so dieses.
Mobilfunk, so große Sache, ne? Also Mobil äh Funkellenabfrage jeden zweiten Tag.
Im Sequetcher stehen überall äh rum, weil wie gesagt, die eigentlich relativ selten zur Anwendung kommen und ich auch,
Im Sequetcher zum Einsatz zu bringen. Der ist der Einsatz eines ist einfach,
zu aufwendig im Vergleich zu den anderen Methoden, die die dir zur Verfügung stehen.
So viel zur Mobilfunküber zu dem neuesten Kennzahlen der äh Mobilfunk Überwachung. Dann haben wir ein ganz interessantes äh Urteil des in,
Im Vereinigten Königreich. Wir erinnern uns, dass äh David Miranda.
Der, ich glaube, inzwischen ehe man von ähm.
Heftig gerne auf die Sprünge.
Vielen Dank von Glen Green World. Ja, äh in an einem Flughafen lange Zeit festgehalten wurde, nämlich äh neun Stunden,
Das auf Basis eines Terrorgesetzes aus dem Jahr zweitausend, das es den Sicherheitsbehörden erlaubt, Reisende zu befragen, um herauszufinden, ob sie Terroristen sind.
Fragst du einfach. Ne.
Dabei haben die Personen weder das Recht, zu schweigen.
Noch das Recht auf juristische Beratung. Das sind also das,
Das Recht zu schweigen und das Recht auf juristische Beratung sind ähm fundamentale Errungenschaften des Rechtsstaates, ja? Ähm.
Die hast du dann eben nicht. Und du kannst bis zu neun Stunden festgehalten werden.
Ähm und.
Dagegen hatte eben der David Miranda geklagt, weil er ja als äh Journalist und so da festgehalten wurde.
Und ähm.
Hatte sich eben dagegen gewehrt und dann hatte stand das vor dem, hat der äh der Hykord hat,
Festnahme für Gesetzmäßig erklärt, weil es ja eben eine Gesetzmäßige Grundlage gibt,
Nämlich dieses Terrorgesetz aus zweitausend,
und da dagegen ist er eben in Berufung gegangen und hat jetzt hat dieser Court of Peel gesagt, ja,
was da geschehen ist, war in Ordnung. Es gibt eine rechtliche Grundlage dafür.
Aber diese rechtliche Grundlage ist nicht rechtmäßig, denn wenn diese Bestimmung.
In Verbindung mit journalistischen Material genutzt werden,
es ging denn ja darum, wo sind die Snowden-Dokumente? Äh,
dann ist das nicht mit Artikel zehn der europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention vereinbar. Ähm und deswegen sei diese gesetzliche Grundlage, die den.
Nicht beschuldigten eine einen Anwalt unters Recht zu schweigen entzieht,
Setz dich nicht aus gegen gegen willkürliche nicht ausreichend gegen äh Willkür äh abgesichert. Was äh total skurril ist,
aber wie gesagt, das Recht zu schweigen und das Recht auf juristische Beratung,
sind sehr fundamentale Errungenschaften des Rechtsstaat
und das finde ich, das war mir schon immer irgendwie äh aufgefallen, deswegen wollte ich diesen Spaßfakt jetzt mal kurz,
äh hier nochmal anmerken,
Es gibt nämlich das sogenannte und das ist das, was äh US-Polizisten, die ihren Gefangenen
sagen müssen, wenn sie sie verhaften. Nämlich so, sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, sie haben das Recht zu einem Anwalt, wenn sie sich keinen Anwalt leisten können, wird ihnen äh von Gericht jemand gestellt und dann gibt's noch einige weitere,
Ja genau.
Ähm wenn es kein, wenn du keinen leisten kannst, geben wir dir den.
Ähm wenn du Fragen beantwortest,
dass ein Anwalt da ist, kannst du jederzeit trotzdem aufhören.
Und dann musst du sagen, sie äh hast du diese Rechte verstanden,
und,
Diese Warnung müssen Polizisten in den USA aussprechen.
Die heißen Miranda, weil es nämlich mal ein äh eine Person gab, die äh verhaftet wurde.
Ähm.
Und sich dieser Rechte nicht bewusst war. Und da gab's einen Supreme Quad Discision und deswegen gibt es halt,
Verpflichtung von Polizisten, dass sie das einer Person, eine Person darüber ähm belehren müssen,
und äh das finde ich halt ein ein Spaßeffekt,
müsst ihr auch noch machen. Das ist Miranda und Miranda, so.
Genau, das war mir ein Ernesto Miranda,
und das äh fand halt in den USA statt äh in Arizona und ja, ausgerechnet David Miranda werden dann sozusagen diese Miranda Rechte nicht zugestanden. Ist schon äh.
Kann man schon gar nicht mehr toppen irgendwie.
Ja, aber okay, da kann man also jetzt sehen, da wird also jetzt tatsächlich ein Gesetz, wo man sagt, du kannst neun Stunden ohne Anschuldigung festgehalten werden, hast nicht das Recht zu schweigen und nicht das Recht auf einen Anwalt. Da wird jetzt also vorsichtig angemerkt, dass das Gesetz nicht ausreichend dagegen abgesichert ist.
Willkürlich angewendet zu werden, also was willst du dazu noch sagen?
Genau, also dieser Code of the Peel ist in äh England im Übrigen, ähm,
ein Berufungsgericht äh auf höchster Ebene, also der hat sich da,
Heilkraut aufs äh sozusagen das oberste Zivilgericht, das hat sich ja äh anders also hat gesagt,
und dieses Berufungsgericht hat halt jetzt gesagt, na ja, äh.
Aber das Gesetz selber ist halt braun und muss äh geändert werden so.
Was ich auch interessant finde eigentlich oder so würde man, ich hätte erwartet, dass in also in Deutschland hätte ich erwartet, dass man sagt, na ja okay,
Das war auf Basis eines Gesetzes, das nicht gesetzmäßig ist, also war's auch grundsätzlich, Mist.
Ja, würde damit hinfällig werden. Ich weiß ja nicht,
jetzt schon äh das letzte Wort ist in dem ganzen Spiel. Auf jeden Fall sagt das ja im Prinzip, dass dieses Gesetz weg muss.
Ja
Oder es muss noch irgendeine Klausel rein, um um ein absolutes Willkürgesetz, wo man keine Begründung, keine Beschuldigung, kein gar nix haben muss, äh irgendwie gegen Willkür abzusichern. Viel Spaß dabei.
Ja dann.
Letzter Teil.
Neues, Nähe, Vorletzter Teil. Neues aus dem äh aus der Generalbundesanwaltschaft,
Ähm Hacking ist not anout in the Bundestag. Ist jetzt äh Peter Frank,
losgegangen und hat die Ermittlungen übernommen. Ähm.
Wer ist Peter Frank.
Peter Frank ist der Generalbundesanwalt.
Der Neue, der Nachfolger, der der Alte, der Alte ist ja weggebrochen.
Der eine war irgendwas mit Landesverrat.
War irgendwas, irgendein Abgrund in den er hineingestürzt ist. Tja,
Da ist Herr Frank noch nicht ganz gelandet, äh deswegen entscheidet er sich jetzt halt auch mal irgendwann mal Ermittlungen auch aufzunehmen. Äh wir erinnern uns, der alte Bundesanwalt hatte ja
Probleme, zum Beispiel mal Ermittlungen aufzunehmen wegen dieses Spionageskandals in Deutschland, von dem man immer wieder mal hört,
weil da gab's ja irgendwie nicht so viele Anzeichen. Also da wird nur seit Jahren drüber berichtet, aber das äh heißt ja noch,
nichts. Aber hier wurde zumindest einmal bemerkt, dass doch tatsächlich so eine Hackattacke gab und jetzt äh
Ja, jetzt können äh die Bösewichter halt einpacken, weil der Generalbundesanwalt hat angekündigt, sich drum zu kümmern.
Er
Bereits also die zuständige,
Fachabteilung zu Bekämpfung von Spionagedelikten,
Also die Fachabteilung der Bund-Generalbundesanwalt,
führt bereits seit Mitte Januar. Wir haben gerade Mitte Januar,
ein Strafverfahren gegen unbekannt. Es geht um den Verdacht der geheimdienstlichen Agententätigkeit und,
Man hat natürlich immer noch keine Angabe über konkrete Spuren, aber der Finger zeigt nach Russland.
Das klingt alles wie so ein bisschen Neuigkeiten aus dem letzten Jahr, sind's auch. Wir hatten das damals auch äh ausführlich behandelt. Jetzt äh ist es auch bis zum Generalbundesanwalt durchgedrungen.
Muss aber auch dazu sagen, es gab quasi vorher eine ein,
LKA, wenn ich das jetzt richtig stehe, was sich damit schon auseinandergesetzt hat,
hatte jetzt übernommen, ja? Ähm.
Wenn ich das äh richtig verstehe. Aber okay, also der kann jetzt, es kann sich nur noch um Jahre handeln.
Und dann haben wir noch eine letzte Kurzmeldung aus der aus der Bundeswehr.
Wir hatten ja beim äh Camp eine eine Sendung mit den Gästen Julia Reeder und Andre Meister und Andre hat sich ja dann damals äh,
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt in den Cyber will und dass die Bundeswehr sagt, okay, es gibt äh Land, Luft und See.
Das sind unsere traditionellen Einsatzgebiete und jetzt,
ein viertes dazu und das heißt Cyber. Und äh.
Die Bundeswehr hat ja, wer im Namen und will sich verteidigen und hat irgendwie die ganze Zeit von ähm.
Von defensiven äh kleidet sich mit defensivem Gedanken gut
Wir erinnern uns an die Debatten der, die so in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren die Bundesrepublik beschäftigt haben
wo die wo die Bundeswehr überall,
unsere Freiheit verteidigt und so, mit welche Länder sie dafür reist. Ähm.
Also zum Beispiel am Hindukusch.
Kuschelt unsere Freiheit verteidigt und.
Demnächst halt auch an der Firewall.
Unsere Freiheit wird auch an der Feierruhr verteidigt.
Firewall verteidigt.
Ähm.
Ja und da war aber immer noch so von passivem, von passiver Abwehr die Rede,
jetzt stellt sich raus, man will natürlich auch äh sich auf Cyber-Attacken vorbereiten.
Ähm.
Nicht die nicht die Abwehr, sondern die Durchführung von.
Genau, die also laut in einem Sachbestandsbericht informierte das Verteidigungsministerium,
den Bundestag darüber, dass Abwehrkonzepte, die über den Rhein,
passiven Schutz zur Minimierung der Auswirkungen eines Cyber-Angriffes hinausgehen. Und diese würden bereits von der NATO unter
sucht. Und sobald die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen für solche
Cyber Defense Operation gegeben sein, würden die Möglichkeiten zur Unterbindung und Beendigung eines Angriffs bei der Bundeswehr geplant und ungesetzt.
Also ja, das ist wieder natürlich sehr schön in sehr schönen,
sehr schöne Wort, Worte, die da sind, also man man bleibt natürlich dabei, wir werden,
im Angriffsfall uns verteidigen mit,
Angriffen, denn Angriffe sind ja die beste Verteidigung. Das scheint das irgendwie zu heißen. Es ist auch ganz interessant, dass sie sagen, sobald die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen sind,
glaube doch eigentlich, dass der Bundestag die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen setzt für die Bundeswehreinsätze oder nicht?
Na also äh wenn wenn der Einsatz ähm also wenn ein Einsatz.
Vorgenommen werden soll, muss der Erhalt äh in der Regel von Bundestag abgesegnet werden. Weiß nicht, ob die da jetzt über einzelne IP äh.
So ein Fünf-Jahres-Ding wahrscheinlich werden. Macht mal fünf Jahre und dann.
Fünf Jahre sein.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Aber nur in einem bestimmten IP-Adressraum.
Ja, wir teilen euch jetzt hier mal ein Subnetz zu. Da könnt ihr dann äh ja, schwierig.
Austoben.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist ja irgendwie auch ähm.
Nachvollziehbar, dass hier Besorgnis herrscht, ne? Aber äh Angriff als Verteidigung, da gehe ich nicht mit.
Na, sie werden das halt ach, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Also sie stehen auf jeden Fall irgendwie ähm.
Gewehr bei Fuß.
Sagt man? Das ist digital.
Tastatur im Anschlag.
Die Tastatur im Anschlag. Haben wir's?
Ja ich ich bin mit meinem Latein am Ende.
Bist mit deinem Datei am Ende.
Am Ende auch nicht.
Kennengelernt keine Ahnung von Latein.
Am Anfang. Ja, also was soll auch nur so Astrid Latein so.
Ja, ja, genau, ja, ja, aber das dafür umso besser.
Ja
äh weiß nicht, haben wir noch irgendwelche Termine anzukündigen, liegt irgendwas an? Von Abend, der ist dann äh bei.
Zwei Wochen, genau, in zwei Wochen.
In zwei Wochen der.
Gute Frage. Der erste Dienstag im Monat, nicht mehr.
Der Dienstag im Monat, genau, ich dachte, wir machen's jetzt einfach mal konkret,
also in Berlin ist und äh sich da beteiligen will, dass der zweite. Zweite Februar,
Ja, vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier,
PN und ähm haben wir sonst noch was anzukündigen Linus?
Mir fällt gerade nix ein. Bestimmt, aber ich hab's nicht. Hast du was?
Ich könnte nochmal in eigener Sache darauf hinweisen, wenn ihr auf äh
Ebene ME geht. Ich äh habe jetzt vor ein Meter Podcast, den ich schon vor einiger Zeit mal so angefangen habe, häufiger zu pflegen und da auch mal immer äh in regelmäßigen Abständen darüber zu berichten, was so in den anderen Podcasts, die ich äh mache und begleite
wo ich vielleicht auch mal zu Gast war, äh passiert ist und warum
hier vielleicht mal weniger passiert und da äh mehr passiert oder auch,
Sendung ich persönlich für besonders gelungen und empfehlenswert erhalte.
Netzbild.
Wie zum Beispiel auch Netzpolitik, genau, das halte ich für besonders empfehlenswert, das solltet ihr euch unbedingt mal anhören.
Aber äh da würde ich mich äh freuen, dass dann auch äh nicht so epische Längen, wie wir sie heute zum Beispiel wieder
haben, sondern dass da mal so zehn, fünfzehn Minuten und das war's dann.
Wir brauchen irgendwann mal Logbuch light.
Nur die Überschriften vorlesen.
Meinst du jetzt mehr so von der Länge oder mehr von von Inhalten.
Von der Länge, wir könnten auch, was wir auch machen könnten, was ich aber.
Promi-Lockbuch könnten wir machen. Logbuch, Panorama oder so.
Oder so.
Nee, wo wir einfach mal nicht immer diese ganzen schweren, tiefen Themen mit Zukunft und Welt und Drama und Krisen und, und, und, und, und, und Krieg und so, einfach mal auch was fürs Herz, ja?
Gossip, ja, neues äh,
oder wer mag wählen nicht mehr.
Die Bunte.
Ja, genau, die Bunte, die Bunte, bunte Tüte für.
Ja, vielleicht fällt es dir was ein. Hm?
Scheiß auch nicht so ganz überzeugt.
Was ich überlege ist, ob wir nicht so dieses dieses Deutschlandfunkkonzept, ich finde das ja immer so geil, wenn du Nachrichten auf den Deutschlandfunk hörst, die Nachrichten im Überblick,
dann lesen sie erstmal so grob die Nachricht vor, da lesen sie die Nachrichten vor,
dann kommt nochmal der Zusammenfassung, ne, dann lesen wir nochmal die Nachricht.
Ach so, am Schluss.
Ja, damit ihr auch wirklich verstanden hast, das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ach so. Ach so, ne, das können wir doch hier auch einführen. Also Sie hörten heute.
Heute bei sie hörten gerade.
Genau, Alexander, das haben wir noch nicht gefragt. Who the fuck are you.
Ach ja stimmt, genau, das wollte ich auch noch fragen, genau.
Bitte?
Wer bist du und wer bezahlt dich? Ja. Was sind deine Interessen.
Deine Treppe. Das hat man ja eigentlich schon, ne?
Eigentlich, eigentlich hat man das schon ganz am Anfang.
Aber wer euch bezahlt hat oder nicht gesagt.
Ja, äh die der Spenderinnen und Spender, Fördermitglieder und ähm OSF gibt uns auch noch Geld. Und die Stadt, wir kriegen von.
Ist, ob ein.
Oben zu sein die Foundation, genau, ja. Und und genau, äh und wir kriegen von der Stadt kriegen wir auch noch ein bisschen Geld hier, von Berlin, von von der Stadt Berlin.
Wieso das denn?
Wir haben hier so ein so ein Jugendprojekt in im im Wedding, wo wir den Kids irgendwie erklären, wie sie ihre Facebook-Profile so einstellen, dass nicht jeder da reingucken kann und ähm da kriegen wir irgendwie ein von der Stadt dafür.
Okay. Auch nicht schlecht. Was ist denn da?
Dürfen das aber nur im.
Mit Facebook Geld verdi.
So, ich merke schon hier mit der Themenzusammenfassung, das wird nichts. Da müssen wir nochmal dran äh üben. Von daher äh verbleiben wir einfach so wie immer und sagen äh tschüss, bis bald. Danke Alexander, danke fürs Zuhören. Äh wir machen jetzt hier Schluss.
Ciao ciao.
Tschüss.